this show is brought to you by the cash
up you know that but we like to keep
reminding you because then the number
one finance app in the App Store the
cash app is the simplest way to send or
receive money especially when your
friends oh you when you owe them or when
you are me the last couple days and
you're trying to get celebrities on
Instagram Live to play the song for you
so you cash up that money that sounded
confusing but it's because all these
celebrities are doing these fundraisers
and they're like if you cash help me
money I'll play your song so I Cash apt
Cecily strong from Saturday Night Live
to play in the air tonight by Phil
Collins on Instagram live it was very
easy I got my way thank you cash app for
making that dream reality
cash job is the easiest way to try and
grow your money as well in the stock
market with their investing feature with
cash up you can instantly invest in any
stock or little as one dollar I was
gonna show you mine but then an X came
up so I'm gonna put my phone away did
you know how that brokerage services are
provided by cash up investing a
subsidiary of square and member si PC
well now you do I just said it and as
always when you sign it for cash up use
the promo code Whitney that's my name
you're gonna instantly receive $10 you
download an app and get $10 I don't know
what more you people want cash ups also
gonna then donate ten dollars to The
Trevor Project an amazing organization
provides Protective Services this is
where Benton would usually read this
sentence but he's not here because he's
being protected by The Trevor Project at
home in quarantine
don't forget the promo code Whitney when
you download the cash app download the
cash app we're not gonna be going to ATM
as much anymore we're not going to use
checks because they're gross and they're
dirty so download the cash app it's now
it's the future cash app in the App
Store today
[Music]
so how do you feel the fact that I put
on a full face of makeup for you you
look really good when I saw you outside
I said oh she got all dolled up I did
because I split my lip open so I'm
wearing red lipstick to try to match the
scab you know I bet you they wouldn't
have known unless you said now you said
it now they're gonna look at it like I
put lipstick in the scab to try to make
my whole mouth a giant if I were if I
was an editor on this I would just punch
in just on your scab the whole episode
or something I bet it's amazing that I
don't have herpes you do what you
actually do I asked my gyno two years
ago you do and I was like don't I have
this and she was like no I don't I that
Sun just as prizes you are you have the
herpes virus so we all had it yeah yeah
you're sure can I give you a weird
medical thing that I've just was
researching Oh God in the same way that
this that coronaviruses h1n1 it's the
same same kind of it's in the same
family yeah it's the same idea of like
chickenpox is herpes zoster virus which
is also huh shingles right yeah anything
different iteration yeah yeah different
branding yeah different yeah that's so
you have a version of her everyone we
don't have the one where it's like pop
popping on your no no well you don't but
everyone carries it
you carry a you carry them like the
motherboard version you don't carry the
strain cuz you know before you do TV
shows you have to go to these doctors
visits oh my god and a lot of times when
you do TV shows you have to make out
with people and there's one actor that
apparently has given pretty much
everyone in Hollywood herpes but like
I've the mouthful really yeah from
kissing them in movies yes I don't think
I can tell you if you guess right though
until off-camera I think it's I can't
get canceled during no I get it Kove it
but let me just like take a while yet
well who was kiss the most people on
camera that we can think of
I would assume would be somebody like um
like a Gosling like a Piven oh well God
cuz Gosling kids been in a lot of it cuz
you got to understand when you shoot a
movie and you kiss someone in a movie
you kiss them for three days oh by the
time you get all the coverage of the
scene you do five takes it's a whole
thing yeah here's your
you harass and I crystal Leah and I have
probably kissed more than anyone I've
dated in real life more he's but he's a
good kisser I don't remember I do I left
before but we were imagine kissing me
what you would do wouldn't it be weird
I've been thinking about it for a long
time like what if we just what if we had
to do a show together and make out all
the time
I think the FIR at the beginning it
would be really hard would you do Tong
or now no what if I did hug
I'd be like cut what is this fucking
lady what do you do yeah a fuse of power
I'd write an article about it yeah I'd
call Jezebel you won't believe it
wouldn't it did no I think at the
beginning it'd be hard to kiss someone
you're friends with it's the heart it's
true yeah I've never had to do that
because you kind of like want to laugh I
mean like this isn't matters but you
have to be that your most vulnerable
like how embarrassing but after a while
you just get used to it Oh Chris and I
would just crack up laughing we couldn't
do it you still could after after a
while we think it's why we got canceled
we could not just these good people
don't like each other at all like we
just couldn't stop we couldn't take it
seriously well have you had it have you
had a nude scene have you been I've had
a couple nude scenes I've had two nude
scenes and pilots that didn't end up
going and the last one which I did like
three or four months ago it's wild
because in the last year because of me -
there's now a job called an intimacy
coordinator where what a person with a
plastic ziplock bag full of mints Wet
Ones and a bunch of stuff just comes up
between takes of you having like
simulated sex with someone completely
naked it's like are you feeling okay are
you comfortable is everything okay do
you need anything which makes it so much
weird or way weirder wait weird yeah see
that's that creeps me that grip it's
already hard enough I'm not gonna
mention names cuz it's not my business
to talk about their business but I
worked on a show and two people had a
love scene and I had Wayne the rock John
that was it it was doing it was Dwayne
and Kevin Hart they were doing a love
scene Dwayne was the bottom and was the
power top power tea nobody these two
people they had to do a very intimate
sex scene and I have to walk in the room
and make a joke cuz they're fuckin in my
room and are they naked everywhere oh
yeah cuz when you're naked on the bottom
you have a strip it's like a maxi pad
yeah yeah a fact back in the day you
know like a
people used to men would wear these um
like banana hammock hot Pease yeah yeah
yeah it's a little like a bag of little
bits a little bag it's like you would
buy your little what Spencer from the
hills sells his crystals that's what
those leftover bags are the no yeah you
put a bag on your cut you literally put
a bat like a bow tie up with a bow tie
and then women will get a it's it looks
like a it's like the inner lining of a
liner of a swimsuit I mean some of these
people don't know what that is guys know
that Oregon all right girls girls all
women no I realize okay
so panty liners yeah it's just and it
goes right over the butt in the hooch
and it's it it's super super revealing
anyway it's sticky dough and you get
sweaty and it stays on for maybe 45
seconds yeah it falls off constantly yes
and so on our thing we had a closed set
so no one could ever it was like only
necessary crew which to me is even
weirder oh my god sorry to be like
setting me to back but a closed set
makes it so much more uncomfortable a
more cuz now we're actually just fucking
yep yeah it's YouTube one camera guy and
me now we're just in a weird orgy if
there's lots of people around I'm like
oh we're working no because nobody cares
right no with this it's like the focus
is on you a less violating if there's a
bunch of people doing totally because
this feels like it's just happening no
one says it job and I would have to walk
in the room you know you have to do the
take 10-15 times cuz it's what I get why
porn like I get why porn actresses are
able to just go like oh this is a job
and stop thinking about oh I mean well
also I'm drinking coffee watching them
do it okay so at some point you have to
be comfortable just being like okay walk
in sexual notes so ugly his butthole was
in my face so I'd walk in in his but the
scene is like his ass holes open in my
face and at first of course I start
cracking up but then I feel bad because
she's that she's hung it's okay for me
to laugh at my naked bodies butthole
yeah always so this is during the scene
err between takes no this is weed this
is uh take okay and I start crack and
I'm losing it and I can feel her energy
being like she's embarrassed and every
time they cut she's wrapping up in the
sheets you know yeah and I was like fuck
I'm trying to make but then I was like
dude don't do that don't do that cuz
she's probably gonna think you're
laughing at her yeah obviously I'm not
it says but she knows his bottles out
yeah but I'm laughing the two naked and
I go out and then I try it again
same thing
I had to take I was like can we take
some time yeah because I need a no I was
like I'm not getting it right I'm this
feels weird
it should I really come and say this I'm
trying to divert from the fact that it's
my fault
yeah I keep fucking up to take yeah my
buddy's nervous or cuz you're seeing
about it's just his butthole was the
first thing I see when I walk in and I
know that's part of the joke of the
scene wait so but the bottle is not on
camera no only I see it I can't think of
well I think that I think they wanted to
do that too man
yeah they were like he's gonna say if
we're gonna make this part of the bit
that he I walk in and see them on my bed
fucking okay okay put his bottle in the
air looking at it's a prank with in the
sexy girl yeah her nightmare I felt so
bad I mean it was like nah I've had sex
scenes before well only one and a pilot
didn't go that the actor that I was
doing the sex scene with his wife came
the day oh why why name the day of the
shoot which was just like unnecessarily
don't show up tense
yeah like you sign you married an actor
I don't know what to tell you you knew
this was gonna happen at some point you
he's good-looking too yes
yeah guess what marry an ugly actor then
all right then they won't be any foxy
Paul Giamatti you went down the aisle
you think he's a lot of sex you think
was gonna happen right he's a big sex
scene is paying for your fucking whole
food it was just like so weird cuz I was
like I'm in this is such a weird
situation I have to pretend I'm really
into your dude oh yeah and I'm only
doing this because I'm getting paid I
know he was there water oh lady
yes and I knew they thought when they
went home like as soon as a woman meets
me they usually like whatever they
either love you or they hate you I don't
think I'm do you think women hate me you
do who do you want me to email no no I
think you have an energy that's very
dominant and I would assume women are
either like French like like you a lot
ha because your vibe or they're like I
don't like that could look in bitch
that's very nice thank you but I think
that I think that before if a girl sees
me without engaging with me like a lot
of people have told me like I thought
you were a bitch and then I met you and
I was I did like a 180 yeah I think I
have a bitchy face and a bitchy energy
until you start talking to me and you
see that I'm hanging by a thread
emotionally don't worry I hate myself
way more than you ever good right you're
a young you're a classic Los Angeles
that you're like for me look at that you
get a closer look look at all these
cracks I would need to redo this whole
fucking thing before I bought it
total total teardown it's the money pit
yeah I mean I'll get into it because it
could be fun just because I like the
history yeah it's gonna be bad it's
gonna be bad like I sort of pride myself
on being able to get all I can get along
with pretty much any woman yeah you
haven't had a like you haven't had one
where you meet certain kinds of women
who don't go well with you that you're
like I can't this is not yes but I'll
figure out a way to make it work like I
never am like this is hopeless see I
think that's the plight of a woman I
think women women because they have this
emotional connection of one another will
try to make it work with someone even if
they don't really like that other woman
yeah men don't do that yeah like we
don't fucking I'm done if I don't like
you I'm done so fan I'm out if you're a
dick to me and your vibe is wrong and I
like your energy I'm not gonna waste any
more time trying to be friends with you
and so how many girlfriends would you
like platonic real girlfriends would you
say you have that you like to talk to on
the phone 7 to 10 wow that's a lot yeah
but but also because a lot of more
comics so it's like you've met them
along the way
yeah really that's what I mean but
outside outside yeah can you make a new
platonic friend as a married man that's
a woman who's not a comedian yeah almost
impossible where I met this I met this
girl at Ralph's oh she's so nice we were
buying the same stuff and anyway we want
to kick it is that cool yeah what what
even could the conversation be like what
like what an impossible land so we're
just buds we just like it's impossible
that's what I hate to be so cliche but
Harry Met Sally knocked it out of the
park and yet when he says to her men and
women almost can't be four it's almost
impossible men and women to be friends
it's really so hard to be just friends
unless your co-workers interesting it's
so hard it's so real when I heard that
in that movie years ago I was always
like wonder if that's true and then you
grow up and you're like yeah it's a it's
so hard to be just friends without any
ties um yeah work it's so hard because
someone eventually is either gonna catch
feelings or get jealous right it's the
nature of what we mean that's it's that
just an
of our community how long have you been
married I don't even know anymore for
years so I have a couple questions wait
a minute wait a minute how many years
before when did you know she was your
wife um
I'm obsessed with the moment yeah
someone goes from this is fun I love
this girl too
I want to sign something yeah I mean I
dunno I mean I didn't I didn't say I
wanna sign something that was my big
that was like a big really paperwork is
I that whole idea always scared me yeah
neither of us even wanted to get married
that was like our whole thing for a long
time like I don't know like it's I don't
even know part of why you bonded
yeah probably and also she initially
didn't the whole marriage and kids thing
wasn't even a part of it like there
wasn't both of us were like I don't
really care if I ever get married or
have kids it was on both of us so we
both were like no you know well because
I for what do you mean as a guy or a
girl like it's just kind of like a thing
we all everyone has always said getting
married
true but everyone ends up getting
married somehow anyway I don't think
anyone wants to get me it's like someone
was telling me a friend of mine was like
no one wants to get married and have
kids
you just get do married have kids and
then you learn to want them Society
forces you to do it and then you die
younger anyway do you feel pressure no
not at all not even a little bit I think
the moment that you're referring to that
I remember vividly was and it's more of
a comedic moment this is why I knew that
we she has a great sense of humor as we
were at a couples therapist and Wow yeah
we got a couple Starbucks we were we
were at a couples therapy sessions you'd
already invested money yeah and that's
really what it was like here's my money
on this fucking check I better lock this
out now we were as a therapist and we
both hated him too we didn't like him oh
no no you know well no we just his vibe
was weird okay I didn't really like his
vibe and watch people break up well
fucking get another job okay don't don't
cut the grass if you don't like mowing
lawns and I mean I can get a new gig but
I but he just his vibe was a little not
it didn't it wasn't cohesive but it
didn't work with us anyway there was a
moment he was in you should be in uh
maybe that's part of his his thing is
that he keeps you together by uniting or
hade for him we both hate this guy I
love you it was in it was by UCLA
Westwood and it was
you know in the westward little area
it's very bustling and busy all day long
as one of those little buildings by the
school yeah and anyway we get to this
moment of we're both like emotionally
breaking down a little bit it's it's
hard it was really balling and I started
crying because it was like a moment it
was a big moment and he just let the let
it sit and it was like silent for like
two minutes
dead silence and we're both kind of
coming down from the emotional height
and no one's saying anything and outside
the window outside the window is trash
pickup and you hear the truck and the
silence yeah we both broke and I just
died laughing he didn't is that funny we
just lost it I was like I should get we
get each other yes it was like oh thank
God we both laughed I was like I hope
when I started laughing I was like fuck
if she doesn't laugh yes oh this is over
cuz it was just the moment of all the
things you know really yeah and then to
hear and then a guy little bit his buddy
and and we just both started cracking up
and I was like okay we're gonna be okay
so why did you go to couples therapy we
were dealing with some bullshit yeah
some heavy-ass issues and we just
honestly I never wanted to do it I'm
cool with solo therapy but couples
therapy I was always like for some
reason I think that's a sham well I also
think that people like us are so like as
comedian we're so wired to win yeah like
couples are for therapy for me always
went in like oh we're both like I'm in
fucking I'm in a court case yeah I'm
gonna be I'm gonna get this guy to say
I'm right yeah the competition um yes
yeah this is where master debaters I'm
gonna win this I'm gonna beat you yeah
and then I'm gonna feel worse about
beating you and and you're gonna feel
worse and ya know I don't said to me
once he goes what do you realize if you
won you've both lost oh God like so I
won yeah but you are saying I did win I
did win this right and you write it down
so I can take it home I want to be right
too badly too right you know it took me
so long to understand that and then I
also was just so resentful about going
because I mean for me I'm always doing
math in my head of how much things cost
and if it's worth it as I'm doing it
so I just kept going like this is $250
it's $25 I'm not getting it like that's
a money thing was on your brow I thought
about really what like can you share
more this is three bucks a more so like
my dad why are you just sitting there
say something you're gonna use it cuz I
bought it like literally drink the milk
it's about to go bad idea like I don't
want to milk yeah well I want you to
want it and then the parking and the
whole thing would you please fucking say
something right and then I'd write stuff
down and really try to get my money's
worth for the hour really yes that
doesn't seem like you do that for some
reason really well this is when I did it
yes years ago yeah but but that's also
because you want to preoccupy your brain
with something other than what's really
going on perhaps whitney therapy and
luke - you know it's true that we always
want to like you know it's hard to see
you know what's almost I said in the
moment that's my I hate that phrase more
than anything in the world because maybe
my being out of the moment is sitting in
it have you ever thought about when
somebody goes oh maybe you're just not
sitting in a moment or enjoying it it's
like well maybe this is my version of it
maybe bitching about the moment is me
and fucking enjoying the moment I tell
you this is why I like you so much and I
didn't know if we would I would like you
because when I first like saw you and I
saw your stannum Rose I know he's really
funny like I didn't think we were gonna
be friends and then I met you and I felt
how much anger you carry Bobby said the
same thing I mean I was like I guess
it's real you do have a lot of in a good
way yeah you're not nothing drives me
more nuts when people are holding in
anger and they're dishonest about it I
let it right oh yes yeah well I feel
like I have my family always had was
that way my mom is openly angry not
passive-aggressive we just say it that's
awesome yeah just say it and sometimes
it's not
I grew up walking on eggshells nobody
says it you bite your tongue and then it
explodes later in the tea pockets that's
way worse okay right and things get
broken and so for us it's more like the
Irish the Irish will push down will push
down hurt and pain yes but will it will
will say shit when it needs to just be
said will I'll push on my own pain and
I'm not gonna let you know about the
things that like devastate you so now I
know why you went to therapy I got that
but I'll just let everything out yeah
something's really making me mad I have
to vocalize it to be like why is this
not pissing everybody off this is so
stupid and annoying we have an obsession
with justice to a degree I have an
obsession with like
I like I like letting I want everyone to
be in on this idea together of like how
come you don't see this yes what do you
mean you don't see this is annoying we
talked about that like the comparison I
made before we started the show of like
when people cut in line and we're all in
it together
I am almost always the guy that goes hey
no yeah and then people kind of look at
you like you're an asshole but you're
like I had to not I had like I didn't
have a choice I'm always the crossing
guard I'm always the person in flights
where if someone I was on a flight let's
back when we flew member the good old
days before civilization ended and this
woman on a plane pulled out a ziploc bag
of hard-boiled eggs no no everyone was
looking at each other and I was like I
got it like I live for conflict I never
get to do it like let me take this one
yeah the one that's excuse me ma'am like
I'm always a volunteer no I you said I
had a joke about it years ago that I
talked about that I saw a guy eating our
boiled egg walking on the plane no hey
you know what Starbucks sells those like
protein packs
that's a mobile fart no that was $12 and
then get on the plane you can't have
that mobile fart with you going in
quarantine fine actually it's great yeah
yeah yeah
it honestly like the the the biggest the
relationship jokes of people being like
oh we're locked up together it's like
now that it doesn't the biggest thing
that bothers me is not doing stand-up
yeah because she's still working
full-time from home yeah I mean she
technically works from home three days a
week she works on home anyway yeah but
but this was just a full-on transition
there was like supposed to be next year
and now we're like well we're doing it
now I just I think I could not be in the
same space with someone 24 hours a day i
require tremendous amount of alone time
to to be able to sew so do you guys just
have strong boundaries of like let's not
talk for the next five hours i just will
go for a run or I'll go somewhere or
she'll take a dog and she'll go out for
a walk or something it's just or while
separate for the other room walk past
each other without saying hi yeah if
we're doing if I'm doing something like
I can't I'm not even the point in
relationships where if we're in the same
place and I'm working in there and we've
got like you good like you can't just no
no when you when you when you're been
together no we don't ever it's like
sometimes it comes out
snap you know when she'll say something
sit and I'll go I'm watching a video and
then she'll go okay and then she'll just
give me the space it's not like that's
not like don't be dick about it no cuz
it's not me being a dick because you're
why are you interrupting me watching the
video you see me watching the fucking
video yeah but we live together and
doesn't matter wanna just wait till the
videos done the video interrupted our
life together baby interruptive a baby
don't paper I love baby I love you okay
I love you just let me finish the video
Texas let me finish the video
hey you don't love that's not love you
know what was I'm not gonna watch videos
anymore you just throw your iPad no just
throw oh you bought it yeah oh you
bought it what a great no truth be told
will just get it'll be quick like what
was that device if it's a very tight as
my phone oh that was my phone you know
it can come off so I can be that's what
I mean when I'm directed that's my thing
I'm what you said is fine just the way
you said it your tone was bitchy but
then when you're with me enough you know
that that's just who you are yeah I
would say it cuz I'm not gonna go can I
finish the video cuz I can't there's no
way I can do it without here let's do it
how many different ways can I say it I'm
still sound like there hey babe
I've got this oh babe I'm watching a
video oh I know but I have this thing I
know I got to finish this video I'm
always gonna sound like I know you don't
I do know you don't but what are you
gonna show me do well here you go you
ready what's the video huh what's the
video it's a guy ice fishing fish
why can't you press pause on that
because I have a jar job that I do 3d oh
okay I have a real job that's still
happening oh the real job gonna keep
going in the nice couple you okay did
you want to marry Brendan because you
signed up to do a job that requires
people exhaling Innocents so what did
you want to tell me like I just want to
tell you about this new cap stick I got
and the ice fishing I don't even pause I
just click it right away yeah but do
you've had phones on mm-hmm no I don't
it's out low you have headphones on you
know how to tell me I already see it I
think headphones can save people's
relationship with headphones to me is a
bigger fuck you that's a don't bother me
at all I don't even you don't exist to
me headphones are shield of invisibility
I'm doing something else I can't hear
you
it's a nonverbal cue that I can engage
with you this is like a childhood game
of like you can't see me
invisible cloak it's like I'm not here
it's like yeah you are you're right
they're like I think if you're gonna
watch a video in the same premises as
your person put headphones on so I
already know before I see you yeah so I
don't have to go like I don't put the
headphones on on purpose so you you can
hear me watching it so that's a hey I'm
watching it you hear it you hear this is
your noise pollution but I'm doing it
I'm working you walked into my room I'm
watching a video well our room it's not
your but you were in the other room I'm
in this room okay but you were in the
other bedroom our mom sure I can't just
in the bedroom all day so you can watch
ice fishing yes you do I have to walk
around the house yes you do my job you
get back in your office you get back in
your room and all I hear is your fucking
guys fishing in the background but it's
like you can't just willy-nilly we just
watch videos all day yes no yes I can't
I just think I would just get annoyed at
the lake what was that yeah what are you
doing are you know like I just go emag
we go if I go far away I go far away and
she knows but you have your own room
yeah that is your that your room when
you go in there I don't knock on the
door well if I go my office it's my
office yeah
don't come in my office how many rooms
you have in this home that already says
46 no know what rooms can she go in so
very humble house just three bed three
bath and she's allowed in the living
room but do you guys have like a set
time with no phones no no but we were
not on our phones in front of each other
unless it's you're not a big phone
person no I mean good on texting no I
know I'm not well because I don't a good
thing I always will return the texts
yeah but I I don't care to engage a lot
on it yeah I'd rather I'm the old way of
like I wish I could just come see you
like I'd rather see people I'd fall also
phone calls don't even get me started
we've talked on the phone before yeah I
know but I hate it I didn't enjoy it
either it's so hard to do it's just like
I don't like it you don't it's obvious
being with you is is my favorite if I
can be with you oh I want to be with you
I like I wanna coz then we can vibe I
can feel your energy it's way better but
like phone calls romantic thing anyone's
ever said okay I just want to be I want
to be with people to deal them I'm
always been that way and I just don't
phones I'm not good like my mom and I I
mean my parents fucking we get it your
parents you're alive
two dads yeah bragging no but I just
feel like that we're not good on the
phone either we're never good on the
phone because they know I'm not neither
are they of like this mmm
keeping up conversation on the phone as
I talk to you when I see you married for
years yeah Wow
yeah but I just yeah so that I just have
a particular way about things that's how
I just don't like what is the main thing
you guys fight about four years in
what's the one thing we fight about the
most yeah um
besides your personality
miscommunication yeah okay
miscommunication I thought this was one
thing you said that you told me this I
thought I thought this meant this got it
like why didn't you said this was gonna
be that this yeah what why did you I
thought it that's what it is yeah that's
really the biggest how quickly are you
able to move through it I say sorry and
we're done and you do that on purpose
because you know it's gonna end the
fight sooner because I'm probably wrong
yeah
sorry is such a magic word I'm sorry it
took me so long to realize that it's not
a failure it's actually a win just say
I'm sorry it just makes it there's
nowhere to go from yeah I'm sorry if I'm
sorry but you have to mean it you can't
go like I'm sorry no bone no no I don't
do those I can't do that nope cuz if
that that's happening that I'm sorry
yeah I just some walk away okay if I'm
in that mental space I forget that I'm a
circle I'm really sorry
like I'm really I'm really sorry that
was stupid I know it was dumb you meant
to be an actor
no I'll know that she'll know when I'm
actually sorry huh because it's it's
like an I let my guard way down yeah
it's like my shoulders are down like I'm
I can I can physically feel being honest
about being like I'm sorry I that I'm
I'm annoyed that I acted that way right
it's just a different feeling why don't
we both burp at the same time oh yeah
really weird weird the same exact burp
Wow question connection
do you ever this is a serious question
from someone that is not married okay
and would like to figure out how to be
in a long-term relationship do you ever
run out of things to talk about
no no because you ever just like do we
covered it can we talk tomorrow like can
we talk them what like can we check in
tomorrow like work I'm good
yeah like can I just go be alone for a
while
do you have to know everything I did
today maybe that's my maybe that's when
I go for a Instagram
no that's check my stories watch my
stories see that's bad follow me
no but we don't have those moments of
like that's like this old way of like
come home for dinner sit down it's like
so what happened today
yeah that's not an existent us but we
don't have a problem talking so usually
I've got we've got some bullshit to tell
me it never feels like work to come home
and fill a person in I guess you're home
all the time now but I just mean like
before no no only because I'm probably
less interested in talking about what
happened in my day you know what I mean
yes I don't want to go over it again yes
so she just doesn't ask interesting
unless I hope she's not gonna be like so
how is that meeting with the guy that
you like the key is that just marry
someone that's not that interested in
you yeah hey yep pepper you would marry
someone marry someone marry someone
who's a cupid with their own career
enough that when you offer stuff from
your career it's then interesting
instead of like what are we talking
about you know I mean like when you have
your own shit going on yes
you have marry someone with a full life
yeah marry someone that's doing their
own that that has interests that are
outside of yours you also have lots of
friends and you strike me as someone
that doesn't try to get all their
emotional needs met from their primary
relationship yeah not even a little bit
a lot of people I know try to make their
husband or wife they're like best
friends
no and I I just that's too much pressure
yeah no we're not best friend we're were
she's my oldest friend we are not
friends
we're not feet we're roommates roommates
no we're she's my oldest friend yeah so
you're a morning sex person yo my god
yeah why that I think most guys are yeah
we are really but why I will you have so
much sperm in your balls it's yeah in
the morning yeah I mean it's just it's
gonna be science I just feel like we're
I just realized how much we're
overthinking it like it's not really a
preference it's just a more of a science
impulsions yeah no it's just I feel
great in that I like fucking in the
morning because I'm comfy I'm warm you
know like the bed is about you didn't
have sex in the morning yeah yeah I like
jerking off in the morning don't you
guys just have to jerk off in the
morning
we've to jerk off at some point in the
day something has to happen with our
penis at some point right
yeah
but I don't like fucking at night
because also you know we ate I'm full
yeah you're nothing worse no I don't
want to like beef I'm gonna fucking a
full stomach it's not uncomfortable like
going on a date the idea of like going
out on a date
eating drinking all night having a great
night it can end without fucking and I
and I feel great because I we had the
time we had a great time we can fuck
earlier in the day right right right
right Morrow morning
I just don't going out getting full and
having sex sounds so unappealing to me I
just I like sex to be like at the end of
the day I just do it - I don't know and
what's the perfect what's the perfect
time it's just I kept like maybe it's
just because as a girl you you're like
it's like a lot to manage yeah you know
what I mean there's still like an
evacuation probably it's just like a
whole thing you gotta do stuff yes yeah
you can't just like get your dick hard
and fuck do you know what I mean there's
like you have to just like but here's
the okay you're just like fucking
leaking the rest of the trustee just
tell him to pull out help yourself a
little bit okay I'm not I'm 37 years old
we don't do things like that nobody
pulls out you say leave it in every time
oh of course not I just I think that
there's a lot of women my I were just
not very bossy when it comes to I'm not
very bossy and bad well you can do it
you can do it the sly way of being like
come on my tits that's like a quick
throwaway of like get it out I don't
want it in yeah yeah you know where I
really want you to come yeah yeah was it
good yeah it's pretty spot-on come on my
tits
come on my Quarantine body level is
because all girls have a list don't you
know stereotypes ranch outside of the
house that's really nice men and women
are different rands yeah oh that's did
you know like that I like that Rams this
episode is sponsored by blue shoe guys
if you're listening I'm gonna cut to the
chase I'm gonna do you a favor get blue
shoe get your dick in order get your
dicks in a row
get all your dicks interlocked in a row
look we're sick of being like I don't
really care how long you can last
bullshit bullshit we want long hard
dicks every girl I know wants to go six
or seven times at least an hour apiece
there's nothing to do we're so bored in
quarantine fuck us long and hard drop
the remote drop the controller go on the
internet get some blue qu you can bone
you can chill and you can bone again and
it's the first shoe a bowl with the same
fda-approved active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis so if you have a gag
reflex with pills oh no problem no
problem whatsoever no problem at all in
fact once you're done guys that blue 2
gets you revving real fast right after
that you can also from what I understand
of the men that have you indulge in blue
shoe and me getting us hit it all of it
and then hit it again in it again again
and again much made my studio blue just
to think about all those hard dicks
can't get enough of them blue cheese
prescribed online by licensed physicians
this isn't some rigmarole yeah these
aren't just guys that hang out near the
local 7-eleven these are real physicians
you don't have to go to the doctor's
office or wait in line into pharmacy cuz
screwed ships right to your door in a
discreet package no one knows but it
doesn't matter even if they did want to
know let him know you got some you got
some delicious chewables they're gonna
make your penis hard
big deal big deal big what big whoop
right now special offer for my listeners
blue shoe calm go to it get your first
shipment free you're welcome when you
use promo code Whitney pay five dollars
in shipping and that's at blue2 dot-com
promo code Whitney try it free it's free
to try don't get a divorce get blue two
instead that's a slogan let us save your
marriage better help you know I love
therapy and I don't like crazy people
you know I don't like when people are
crazy you have no excuse to be a crazy
person anymore cuz of better help better
help it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online a lot of you're out
there in quarantine
and batshit crazy and you need a
licensed professional therapist online
not in person because those days are
over this is a way to get therapy on the
internet with no germs it's available
worldwide you can log in your account
anytime send a message to your counselor
you can get timely thoughtful responses
with your online therapist weekly video
phone sessions this is the future you
guys the days are gone where you going
to a nasty germ covered therapist office
with the little rock garden that you
scratch and you washing your hands
constantly those days are over
therapy is only online with better help
more affordable than traditional offline
counseling I'm so excited that I'm
drooling on myself excuse me
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today I'm sick of you guys
being crazy I'm tired of it and you know
it the jig is up get an online therapist
better help calm slash Whitney better
help H ELP join the over half a million
people taking charge of their mental
health and that mental wealth with the
help of an experienced professional
special offer for good for you listeners
here you get 10% off your first month at
better help calm / Whitney time to stop
being crazy you're welcome but I I'm not
like a bossy person in bed but I do
really like the morning sex thing I try
to just like to me coffee is so much
more important than sex huh you know I
mean yeah but having a cup of coffee
after you fuck together is great I get a
my I get a headache if I don't have
coffee like right away
really that you have initiated I have a
probably cut that yes yeah no shit we'll
get help okay and you have to have a
cobbler you need an IV drip of coffee
before you follow yeah if I don't have
coffee within the first like 20 minutes
waking up I will get like a throbbing
headache oh that's really how many cups
a day um I have one in the morning and
then if I'm podcasting one in the
afternoon that's it huh that's it sounds
like this if I'm someone that has it all
day long no it's I just have a very like
I get migraines and I also once I get
have to brush my teeth because I cannot
have sex with morning breath it's too
disgusting
you can we just don't kiss but I'm still
self-conscious
we both are both parties are yeah but
what are you just just over you know
kiss if I I have morning Buster oh but
then I have to taste it it's not for
about you I don't care about you
smelling it I don't like having morning
breath I'll see I'm the opposite I don't
want her to smell it well I have that
too but I don't want to smell her so I
just your mouth is all crusty yeah but
just go down just suck it or something
suck it and get it started
I'm sorry suck it and get it can't smell
it you can't smell your morning breath
so dehydrated will they keep up the
glass of water you don't keep water by
the bed I mean what am i dead okay so
you want me to wake up swig water and
just start sucking your dick
I'm not saying out of a fucking a gallon
jug when you're not taking a Sparkletts
container
look at this here it is ready it's like
good morning good morning
yeah it's so easy a little bit of water
by the bed by the way I don't know
anyone that doesn't keep water by the
bed I do but I what if it's not enough
why like I don't know how is this Larry
David who am I talking to how much water
if it's enough if it's alkaline water if
it's sink water just get a couple
fucking water and suck a dick will ya
like it's just a lot of logistics and
like by the time I'm just like I'm
overthinking it when I check my phone
like I'm up that's what it is yeah
that's what it is I check my phone and I
get your dick is just not my problem
I've tried then I'm gonna put a picture
of my dick on your phone like I just I
just jerk off if you're gonna do it what
would you have a problem if he jerked
off next to you in the morning it
depends on I guess what he was how he
was turned on by you and wanted to hook
up I'm like on the phone but you're not
in the mood if you're it's your early
morning like I don't really want to and
he's like well I'm so horny I want to
jerk off talking about you or you just
yeah touching me or whatever you're cool
with it but then what am i doing I have
to know what I'm doing I don't know
occupy yourself well might as well just
get out of bed no way oh no you might as
well just handle it or get up I'm not
gonna lie there while you so this is a
lesson for men uh-huh if your girl says
to you not in the mood just start
jerking off and see what happens maybe
she'll handle it I might run out of the
room crying frankly it's your boyfriend
I know about a stranger's I think
there's something that happens when
you're in a relationship where like the
idea you go like oh they don't jerk off
anymore or in a relationship of that's
insane oh no I know but I think a lot of
women are just like oh yeah he doesn't
jerk off we have sex do you slow down
when you're in a relationship
masturbating if you're in a relationship
I never masturbate fine relationship
that's know that I haven't true hunt
show your house you're having sex enough
to something I built this house on life
yeah literally this is called lie
stereotype ranch i layer the line layer
by layer but your frequency goes to zero
I do not masturbate one smidgen when I'm
in a relationship only because you have
enough you have enough unless I have to
like do it on FaceTime or some shit
because there's enough compliance where
you're like I get sex when I need it
enough that I don't need a masturbate
yeah really yeah
what's your frequency normally then not
high okay that's why like at all yeah
your sex drugs your sex drive super low
right kind of is if I'm not in a
relationship it just feels like a lot of
once you get in and you're ready to go
once I'm in a relationship like this a
switch turns on but when I'm not in
relationship the switch just turns off
when I really don't think about it
really yeah cuz you preoccupy yourself
with other things like work and and fun
yeah it's just like but I also just have
a really hard time watching porn because
and I and I'm so curious if this happens
to you no I don't think I've ever asked
a compliment it's so hard to watch porn
without thinking of trying to think of
jokes it's so hard to just watch porn
without being like I should write a joke
about how they're all doing on yoga
balls now like it's like I can't turn
that off I can't I turn it the switches
all the way off there's an animated porn
now love it by the way really what's the
allure scene all the numerous different
yes yeah all the people like it's not at
some point when you run out of the same
scenario you've seen a thousand times
yeah you come across like sometimes I'll
throw something on your page that's like
there's that there's a video game or not
maybe not video
yeah it's called overwatch uh-huh he
knows it what does that mean
overwatch is like a video is it a video
game it is right not if it yeah but they
do porn on this video game and it comes
up on pornhub sometimes and I've watched
it a few times it's is it but it's a
cartoon characters they're like I'm
looking at my deaf yes it's great and
they are like but what is the Elora
because it's superfan it's ultimate it's
like fantasy fantasies sometimes they
don't even look like humans you know
like aliens or there be different colors
and shit yes cuz it's like stepping out
of the realm of normalcy I've seen black
I've seen five black guys on one girl
I've seen I've seen the plumber I've
seen the brother I've seen all the
things are you worried that there's a
point where you can't come back from
that
no no we'll never run out we're good
it's an endless comedy porns have you
seen the skit comedy sexy skits no on
pornhub baby it's just my algorithm but
you go in and it's like girls it's like
a skit Oh like a bad skin yeah yeah
we're they're doing it on purpose what
the curl like it's like I'm coming home
and then the guys fucking the girl and
her bunk my mouth is like if I see that
I'm gone like there's a scenario comedy
people might know there's a scenario
where like girls get stuck under a bed I
know this freak knows it I know he can
hear it what there's like a bit joke of
pull on there's like a subversive joke
in the porn world of girls getting stuck
in a thing and their asses are out you
know what I mean and the guys let me try
to help you get out and they end up just
like a dick just like falls out it's
yeah but they've done it so much it's
become like this meta joke in the porn
bang bus right it's like now it's like a
joke of itself but it's actually still
porn right it's really weird it was like
girls getting stuck on her bed then it
was a girl stuck in a washing machine or
like I get turned off by bad acting yeah
that's why I don't that's if I see bad
acting and porn I can't focus and then I
start writing jokes and then at the
moments over see I don't know if I see a
bad if I if it becomes too much of an
acting scene yeah I click I'm out I'm
out right away
setup that's why this oh this why this
animated portal thing is interesting cuz
it's it's super fantasy but don't they
look weirdly like aliens always look
young to me
yeah it's great I'm always fuckin fuckin
26 year old alien I mean I just
imma do you at all worried like have you
ever taken time off porn I don't watch
it I don't watch it that much do you
have your and I'm fascinated by people
who are monogamous and porn who have
like in their porn star they go to oh no
I don't do that shit you're just like
it's not I don't couldn't care less I'm
never gonna remember your name if the
porn stars the name thing is hard for me
why do you think guys go to specific
porn stars because it reminds them of
their mother
no I don't know it probably reminds them
of no truth maybe there's some fuckin I
mean did you think that they think
they're in a relation with this person
or they just like the way that girls it
does her thing yes I think men are will
get obsessed with the porn star when it
is the it's the ultimate compilation of
all the kind of woman that they like
because I kind of do with newscasters
you like it one person you trust are you
trust by the way in the news like well
no you just get emotionally attached to
whom oh my god lemon or whatever
everybody loves up you're just like
you're like that's my guy right that's
just like I know what I'm gonna get ya
know I can trust this guy oh you know
what yeah these things aren't alike at
all not even like I know she's gonna
know that's not what she's capable of
that's comfort this is this it's this
this is it this is this is the exact
formula of a woman that you like cuz I
get confused because I thought the whole
point of porn was to see someone that's
not the person you see naked every day
and then you two go to the same porn
star every day it's like doesn't that
defeat the whole purpose of what porn
supposed to do no because they puts
himself
they put themself in all sorts of
scenarios that will always be changing
so it's like it's like you're it's like
cucking it's like cut career look good
you know what cooking is not really I've
heard about about Chuck is like when
someone watches their significant other
fuck someone else and they get off on
what is that why I think a lot of people
are into that yeah what is that well
it's it's like it's like very um what
does that when you self-inflict when you
love pain when you're sick but you're
masochism masochism yeah yeah you like
the hurt of being let down of like oh
she's fucking this other guy and his
dick is bigger than mean he's I didn't
you fight after I don't know I feels
like it's I don't know why people like
it but I think it's because people want
to feel the hurt they like no but in the
porn world that's what I'm saying is
like I think people like to watch a porn
star on a bunch of different scenarios
because it's like it's a okay because
people men disassociate so they're like
this is not a real person anyway to them
yeah you know I'm saying a lot of men
are like this is my play toy it's a fake
world I got I get I went on Twitter
which I'm not into which I don't agree
with I'm just saying these are real
people what yeah
once you jerk off to they are the real
people get off the Smurfs at this boy I
jerk off to everything by the way some
of those Smurfs are fucking hot I used
to trust who was coming out I can't wait
to see the porno for that like
threatened by porn and now I'm like
weirdly fascinated by it I love it I've
become friends with a couple of porn
stars and they're like the greatest
nicest yeah honest people about it
because they've I think the stigma has
changed over the years there people
still judge it yeah but now porn stars
have been given more of a voice to be
like oh fuck you you can't you can't
talk bad about me and also come to me
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can't treat me
like shit and then be like didn't you
jerk off to me right like you it's just
I think that we've there's a balance has
started to set in societally of like I
did it down your guard TV show this was
years ago and I had put jenna jameson in
it and there was a bunch of celebrities
in the show when she showed up on set it
the vibe was so fucking weird why
because everyone had come down after her
for so long
yeah and the I cannot explain it like
John Cleese shirt all these like legends
were showing up on the set she everyone
was freaking out because it's like they
were so close to this person right but
had never seen in seen you in person
I've never seen a level of like people
being starstruck the way we did when
jenna jameson mark oh wow that's what I
mean it's a level of celebrity that like
I think athletes also have like I worked
on something with Blake Griffin when you
go with with an athlete it's a it's like
a religion it's like a DAT is well
they're superhuman yeah they're they're
superheroes yeah they're just where's an
actor people like a man and they start
giving you career advice
yeah or their order like I hated you in
that thing and you're like oh thank you
you know it's funny yeah oh god oh my
god fucking people just come up to me
and give me career advice have you ever
done Ellen you should do Ellen you know
you should be on Grey's Anatomy
have you ever dived I've ever done that
you should do that yes my failure is not
funny that's men who is not a funny
woman can I tell you I don't like I
don't think female comics are funny but
you sometimes you pretty good will you
get that from a man or a woman I get it
from both mostly men come up to me a lot
and they just tell me how unfunny other
female comics are a lot of them whom are
my friends
mm-hm and so they're just like roasting
my own friends and from what do you say
I just I'm like great thank you
like I just start saying thank you and
try to get out of there if we're on a
plane together and I'm stuck oh I'll
just be like comedy subjective it's a
democracy yeah there's something
different for everyone
everybody likes what they lie you don't
have to like everything yeah totally
yeah no I get I get that I mean I just I
just don't tell anybody in public if
they if you're sitting like someone and
they don't know who you are
mm-hmm I'm definitely never gonna tell
them that I'm a comedian no no yeah no I
can't but if they're in it like this
woman engaged with me enough on the
plane she was being very nice because
she got nervous because the turbulence
and other stuff and she started to open
up heavily about who she liked who she
didn't like but you get big Bill Cosby
fan really recently yeah she loved him
good for her loved him
yeah it's a very good stand-up yeah she
goes I really love she know she said I
hate his I hate everything about him
I hate everything about him but I just
respect him that's what I think that
interestingly he kind of like what
happened with him obviously made me
realize like I love back to the point
about I love angry people and dark
people that are openly angry and dark
because they're you know there's no
secrets whereas like I always had a
weird feeling about some of their was
just like jello it was like who are you
really
and what who's to openly like positive
and like I just said it is that if
you're too happy something's going there
shoes gonna drop like what are you
hiding where are the kids
we're the bodies where they like I just
if I see open anger I feel safer around
people because you know like it's like a
it's like a constant struggle
instead of like when you're hiding and
you're happy all the time is like well
something's really deep there's a deep
cut yeah it's like I would rather you
just sort of show warts-and-all like up
France yes I mean yeah you've gone back
to the words think twice with the herpes
yeah do you want to tell me is there
something you need to say oh that's
gross I love you warts and all even is
it was it was you to ward nakorn my gosh
all the listeners have checked out they
checked out when I was fucking jerking
off to alien porn both bad I it's pretty
much the thing I like to do on this
podcast is is ask questions to guys that
girls never get to ask okay let's do it
I get a lot of like advice
because I think that most women get
fucked by taking advice from their
girlfriends that's probably true if you
want advice about your man ask a guy
yeah I'm asking your single girlfriend
because they're gonna they're gonna
placate you're gonna tell you what they
like maybe he likes you too much
no one's ever liked anyone to real I
spent my entire 20s being like he likes
me too much
I guess that's why you won't call me
yeah it's so fucking confusing and then
I would ask a guy and they'd be like no
dummy did like you at all they'll find
you if he wants a date you will find you
it's like you know yeah and so uh and
the other one that um here all the time
is like um he's afraid of getting hurt
no doesn't exist for guys no man has
ever been afraid I'm getting hurt maybe
by their dad that's like you only like
guys like get on fucking fucking
skateboards we don't carry down don't
care the only person that can hurt a man
emotionally is his father oh yeah
I mean seriously yeah no that's the only
the only person I can emotionally like
really recognizes that so if a guy's not
interested in you he might think your
dad his dad doesn't like you and
therefore he's afraid of getting hurt
yep by a rejection cuz your and I are
good enough life that's right perfect
math lecture have you you want to show
you watches a succession on HBO that
show like that is the proof that is much
that is beyond but so much proof like we
see a lot of mass we see a lot of these
daddy issues with women who see the
stereotypes of this quote-unquote daddy
issues but this is a real daddy issue
with boys and it's the best version of
like here's how men struggle with daddy
shit I love you say that because I think
a lot of people go lick his weird shit
with his mom no dude it mo more guys
have weird shit with their dads cuz
there's this I want to I want to make
you proud I want to be I want I want you
to be happy about what I do and be like
excited about what I do and but also DS
and their dad they wanna like the day
you beat your dad in sports is if you
play sports is the greatest day in your
life right as a boy you're like I fuckin
be my dad at basketball there's this
weird changing in the gone see you to
beat him some debts some dad's don't I
feel like I would pretend I would make
myself smaller so that the my primary
caretaker didn't think I was trying to
take their life no but was raised by
narcissus yeah I'm just gonna say you
weren't allowed to shine too bright
yeah turn it down that's what they'd say
yes turn it down yes no this that's
you're showing off yeah you're showing
yeah you're being yeah you're being a
ham
Whitney enough enough yeah and that hurt
a lot that would be on my grapes that
hurts a lot yeah Whitney enough yeah
anyway it was uh you oh you think you're
better than me oh that's tough well
that's that's mean that's actually I
mean am yeah I am I don't think so and
I'm gonna prove it yeah and it's gonna
take me a career but I'm gonna do it
your generation was a fucking mess it
doesn't take that much to be in the car
to my dad last time I was home I go well
thanks for fuckin up the housing market
you know you're gonna talk about how our
generation sucks you got to be a
millionaire to buy a fucking piece of
shit I've been drugged for 30 years
thanks a lot thanks a lot how's all your
secretaries you guys don't believe in so
that's that's the balance of the the
father-son is I want to make you proud
but I also want to beat you a little bit
that show does it the best version of
like I want to make you proud but I want
to beat you like I want you to show that
I'm I want you to know that I'm I'm good
I want to read this thing I was fighting
with something do you like the movie oh
I have a theory that every guy that has
dad issues favorite movie is no country
for old men it's not my favorite but
it's a great fucking move every guy that
like like admires their dad loves that
movie oh that's a great movie though
would the movie be as good if that
wasn't his haircut be honest yes not
that good of a movie if it is hair looks
any different it is a good movie also
where's he from in that movie it doesn't
matter where is he from
it's a novella we pretending like that's
a good accent it is it's in a vacuum we
it doesn't matter where he's from big is
not too long big as my big is my
favorite movie
Wow do you think Tom Hanks really turned
into a man in that movie it's a great I
love the fantasy of those I miss I miss
fantasy in films so when it comes in I'm
all for it I'm gung ho I don't need you
to explain it to me I you don't need to
believe what's happening in the movie in
order like it no exactly in fact I like
it more if it's more an unbelievable
because then it's more fun we're then
we're operating on the idea Dumb and
Dumber we're operating on the idea these
two morons could make it across country
with the woman's okay but not the comedy
it's different it's supposed to be
ridiculous every movie is ridiculous
what we're fake we're faking a thing
it's ridiculous but I just I think that
there's a couple movie
that I like what's your favorite movie
big it just it touches no it's not my
favorite it's one of what our controls
in the outfield
what is hello Durham no let me guess
you're moving no fucking the one with
the with the Kevin Costner with the kid
in the bushes kid Field of Dreams Kevin
Costner kid in the bushes had a file
what did they put back the greatest pedo
no it's either Field of Dreams no hold
on you're from Chicago
yeah it's either Field of Dreams it's
not Old Country for Old Men which by the
way I'm gonna read a text about in a
second the one with the dude Big
Lebowski yeah that's a great movie
that's not my favorite movie Shawshank
Redemption
no but that is a great mother you 36
okay
Pluto Nash no you did you play football
Rudy no I played basketball so you say
Hoosiers no no white men can't jump such
a good movie because I'm obsessed with
just ask someone their favorite movie on
the first date and I can tell you how
they really should person is but this is
very this is woman woman brain man brain
okay
men don't my men have a million
different movies that we love because
they represent all different times in
our life okay what's your one favorite
movie how is that possible to pick I
don't
yeah I could do it I could tell you my
least favorite movie Oh tell me that the
la-la-land
I fucking loathes of that movie I hate
it I hate LA I hated it so much it was
unbelievable dancing on the cars on the
fucking freeway everything about it was
so contrived I don't care I a movie
I hated it hated it you don't like
musicals loathe I loathe musicals do
annoy the fuck out of why are we singing
it's just like like it's just always
like I don't what's happening or how
about this does anyone know what
happened in wicked alright now it's the
time that we talk about it
you know what that is pubes let's talk
about them let's dig in they're
sickening they're disgusting there's too
many of them
this is a this is a biological flaw
pubes are a mistake get them off your
dick get them off your balls get them
off your butthole manscape them okay I
cat out like a big giant swampy mass
brillo pad of pubes man scape your shit
okay
this company has redesigned the electric
trimmer it's called the lawn mower 3.0
mow that lawn all right
skin safe technology this trimmer will
not snag on your taint and your ball
sack and your nuts and your bolts it
whatever elses it's down there I try not
to look but you got to keep that shit
tight just cuz we're in quarantine
doesn't mean you can't
you're not gonna shore everything up
okay we want to Schwinn a shave it up
you're gonna get this lawn mower 3.0 and
then you really got to work on the stink
factor as well okay you also got to get
something that's called the crop
preserver and crop Reviver I think your
dick is the crop this was supposed to be
corn I think it's out now it's making me
a picture of corn it works these
products keep balls from sweating
smelling and sticking I know it's during
quarantine we're not showering a lot you
gotta just you gotta make sure you don't
get that Wharf smell down there okay
these products smell delicious manly
scent it's gonna help spice up the mood
okay you're also gonna get a pair of
manscape boxer briefs that's gonna keep
your junk having less funk okay you're
gonna get 20% off plus free shipping
with the code Whitney manscaped comm
gals this is the perfect gift for your
man and man it's the perfect gift for
yourself trust me I want all your balls
get all your balls in a row okay
because I from I've been on reddit
recently and your dick and balls are
and you get 20% off free shipping with
the code Whitney and manscaped comm
that's 20% off with Free Shipping at
manscaped
dot-com use promo code Whitney Thank You
manscaped for cleaning up the swampy
balls love you oh thank God for this
company door - let's talk about it door
- is here to solve the biggest problem
you have right now which is that you
want food you're hungry but you're
terrified to leave your house and if
you're anything like me you refuse to
cook because frankly we've worked too
hard and the last thing we all need to
be doing right now is dishes life is
stressful enough right now door - is the
app that brings you the food you're
craving right now - you're home ordering
is super easy through door - app choose
what you want to eat your food will be
left safely outside your door no drama
no handshakes no hugs six feet away from
you gonna drop it right off genius
three hundred thousand partners Wow in
the u.s. Puerto Rico Canada and
Australia you could support your local
restaurants which we all should be doing
like Chipotle Wendy's The Cheesecake
Factory
you name it many of your favorite local
restaurants are still open for delivery
don't forget that use door - to help
support them right now our listeners are
gonna get five dollars off their first
order of 15 dollars or more so that's
like a bunch of Nuggets that's like
we're basically covering your like side
of broccoli raab rob a never know what
that was zero delivery fees for the
first month when you download door - app
and enter the code Whitney that's five
dollars off your first order and zero
delivery fees for a month when you
download the door - app in the App Store
code Whitney
five dollars off with your code Whitney
do not screw me on this door - put the
code in Whitney five dollars off get
yourself a side of fritters enjoy a lot
of guys I know that are married
condoms because they say it like like
spices things up for these Psychopaths
that yeah that's an insane human being
what kind of mentally unstable guy wears
it you get married so you don't have to
wear it started using condoms as my wife
it's kind of like makes it more fun no
it doesn't that's that's the dumbest
thing I've ever heard of my fucking life
go go tell that to a 17 year old who
hasn't felt it without a condom yet and
then when he does and he's like what are
you fucking are you alive if it makes it
feel like like sex with a random
stranger or something no it does no it's
if condoms are an inconvenience yes
it's why so many people don't use them
that should in the first place yeah I
couldn't in your marriage know
disgusting gums everything like I
haven't really spent a lot of time
thinking about how disgusting calm
have you ever put a condom on a guy
you're dating never yeah I don't think
the answer's no I'm too afraid of
failure like because I've always worried
I'm gonna get it backwards it's weird
because get it back like cuz you don't
inside-out that's funny because if you
it's so now that I think about it it's
so dumb why would any guy want a girl to
be really good at putting condoms on you
want them to fumble a million no you
want them to be good at it
I it's like the old concept of like
would you rather have a girl that sleeps
with a lot of people safely or or no
people on say or like oh interesting
I've never put a condom on before I must
have everything yeah well it's like I
don't know how to work with a condom
it's like well why not I don't that
doesn't know liar mm-hmm we shouldn't
use one what is it like the idea of when
you first start dating someone now which
I have yes when you're back out what am
I gonna do by the way that's good luck
what is my plan here mmm get a get a
what what I date Who am I gonna date do
you want to be a sugar mama just get
somebody to pump no if I pay if I pay
too much for someone else it starts to
feel like incest pretty fast why family
it feels it feels like I'm it's my son
Oh we'll get someone older then just
date someone older than you and pay
which I've always done well then it'll
feel like a dad it'll feel yes this will
be all like full circle who would I date
who would date me my eyes twitching I
just got so upset are you doing the apps
oh yeah oh yeah we're all right
hey I want to say I went on the dating
app it's it's definitely bleak and
Quarantine because the apps are on fire
right now because people are so fucking
bored yeah but without any hope of
actually fucking they're just flirting
so I'm not on tinder
obviously that's below you I don't know
whether it's not not I get I know him do
you want to see I'm gonna show you Riya
cuz you've never seen it you never know
I don't ya know you've never been at you
were married before dating app started
dating before but together before the
dating I started Wow for the craze yeah
Jesus Christ you want to see the men or
the women
mom this is Riya this is a dating app
that you have to like get accepted to
it's a big deal this is the Country Club
of dating app yes yeah you have to have
someone to give me give me who are you
guys yeah we're see the guys okay but
you can't say their names sure that's
right I'm gonna give it to you okay so
this is a dating app that's like
Hollywood people I know who that is
you know this man's a writer yeah how
many these guys do now I know most of
the guys let me see you're so old
just him you want him press play and you
can watch them like a video of his
pictures just hit his v-neck hit the
v-neck yeah and you can see a bunch of
different pictures and there's a song if
you turn it up you put select a song
also what song did he Vic oh god that's
a one direction yeah well you try to me
I hate when guys the dating I was trying
to make jokes with like a hands so I
said I say no to that one right so do X
no yeah goodbye I'm hidden right now so
I won't see anyone who's that I don't
know that person but they must be very
rich to have looked like that and be on
the side I can say the first name
without saying the last name right ah
sure I just don't like when people
spelled Jeff would you off like the
worst off your name is G your name is G
off hi I'm Jeff oh nice to meet you Jeff
so je FF uh no it's good good yeah
no it's not je oh about your golf F G Oh
F at 2 FS
yeah you're gonna have your golf half of
these letters or not necess and you're
gone
he's kind of cute Chris Chris Martin
oh he's got fast pictures oh yeah that's
a lot of purchase a lot of I don't like
I don't like a leather jacket with a
cuff I don't like a cuff leather jacket
you like leather jackets in general no
yeah so that's a not of no shine no
Sheen I want no sheen on my America it's
a lot of chin you know I don't guys know
to do photos up why do you guys hold
them down so I do you guys want me to
see your chin
well I think motion this is what you
want me to like picture what it's like
to be under you oh this is when we wake
up this what you see bitch that's no
guys always take photos under their chin
and girls always do above so to inform
men what is that what's the preferred
picture of lineup what are you supposed
to have a photo of I have the minimum
number of photos on your profile if the
minimum number is three three always go
for the low always go for the minimum
number of photos I want to see at least
one dog whether it's yours or not I want
to see a mountain and then I want to see
a very simple picture of you that you
didn't take yourself work photo this guy
had almost everything he just said he
had a dog to tupik dog look how many
photos are okay so this is an incessant
number of photos he's putting 55 photos
of himself on here and he's not that
good-looking isn't that strange did he
put up a lot when he's not balls like it
the number of photos is not gonna help
you it's what's this he's cute but can I
tell you something agent the age range
surprised well I put it my age range is
like 35 to like 45 or 50 yeah 50 because
it was I don't know why I think that was
more to try to see if people in
Hollywood are on it would you not I
think I do the age range actually like
twenty to fifty cuz like very famous
people are on this would you do would
you do that is would you do thirty he's
cute is thirty two young for you
yeah probably really you think I like
yeah I don't know what if it's an
established xxx a guy he has a nice
career he missed thirty famous thirty
move it's a famous thirty famous thirty
is the thing yeah this is a content
creator is this person's job content but
create but also wait wait let's give it
also looks like he's at a rehab he
decided there he's gonna be Eddie Ford
he's like near like a patio but what if
what if what if he but seriously uh huh
what if he's being humble right look
what if you lie about your occupation
because you're just being humble cuz you
don't want to be that guy on there
concentrators vague enough words I don't
think guys on bet on dating apps would
be humble you need to peacock this is
your time to peacock is that Neal
Brennan Neal Neal Brennan know what's on
here for a while yeah he was yeah yeah a
lot of our friends are on this dating
app and it so he
kind of hot let's see we have friends in
common I like that's a good photo it's a
guy it's a selfie with his dog kind of
in the picture and he's not showing a
whole face he did he did then the second
photo can be a way to hide a receding
hairline or it could be humble and like
cute and would you date a bald guy I
would yes I think bald is hot what's
good what's the kind of guy you knock in
a date so statistically there's a there
was an amazing study that came out that
said women are more sexually attracted
to men that are bald because of how
alpha it is what does that mean like
Jason Statham types like that sort of
thing there's something hot about it
because it is like because they take
yeah it's just like a primal attraction
baldness really hmm
because the high levels yeah you love
not see through that jump that one right
in real fast hope we isolate that passed
around the internet Whitney just going I
love Nazis
I love Nazis if someone's trying to be
artistic is that okay or no no it's a
too artsy fartsy there's this is a black
and white photo and it's a lot of weird
profiles or money of the men you've
dated white oh he's actually cute did I
yeah most the men I've dated are white
most of them yes have you did it any non
white men I have what are the stretches
of races that you've done let's go over
it you live Nazis your fuck yeah well we
know what your favorite is but Dan saw
your profile when it was visible what is
that I'm hidden right now oh do you like
enforce it without telling me I did I
like Dan you said you liked him
you're right you're right yeah so does
that mean he mastered me you're hidden
so you can't connect however if you
unhide your profile will show you Dan
again so he liked you when you weren't
hidden study oh but did he message no I
don't know how to do all men are
perceived as more attractive and
masculine conducted by a survey written
by George Costanza written by an obvious
bald guy you study from University of
Pennsylvania my alma mod is it really
from penofin do jason statham Jeff Bezos
and Bruce Willis have in common they're
extremely successful state them and
Willis are Hollywood superstar and oh
shit Bezos one of the richest men in the
world with her Amazon yeah we know
in fact there's something about bald men
that a according to a study conducted by
the University
all men are perceived to be more
dominant and successful according to
whom around that this is this is like
family feud to like 100 women you're
like yeah where Jason showed that guy
yeah scientist Albert II Manus who was
bald himself fake recorded the reactions
of people who were shown a series of
pictures of men the participants were
shown a picture of one man twice once
with a full head of hair and one with
his hair shaved and bald or two
different things right okay
all the respondents admitted they found
men with shaved head to be more dominant
bigger and stronger that shaved head not
bald head but it says bald I don't tell
you bald men are perceived as more
attractive in masculine I'm not saying
they're not I'm not saying that you
shaved your head would you shave your
beard too hmm I know I have to have my
beard have you had your not never not
had your beard I've almost never not had
a beard I've had a beard since I can
remember
how's your wife seen you without a beard
yes how'd it go not good that's what we
were a couples therapy when I told you
about an hour yeah she's like I don't
get it it looks disgusting without her
you not why I've always liked hair I
don't my face I don't know I don't like
the way I look without it I look like
boy you love a beard so I've always
liked hair on a face I think it's like
an indicative of like um but sharper is
it soft oh I just trimmed it so feel it
I don't know what it oh my god what did
I just almost make you do in this
climate Jesus Christ I don't want to
touch that I almost made you touch my
second face you didn't even think twice
like here we go I really do want to know
if it's up what do we do if we're in the
time of kovat if we want to feel
someone's beer you got to put gloves on
can we date I mean what if someone asked
me on a date actually you can go on a
date in these times yes where how if
they've been quarantined and you've been
quarantined I just think you know where
we two go on a hike I think we're not
supposed to do that I mean we could
stand across the street and just yell
like when we were kids I look my best
six feet away I feel like this is I
don't want to be six feet from someone
and then all this and this be over and
then be like uh like geez just gotta
find glass go back to the old days yeah
I think you could date no you FaceTime
dates oh man oh man that's not a thing
is it you
is there VR dating right now I think if
you meet someone a dating app right now
your face time in for a couple months
just like jerking off you know that's so
creepy yeah and you're sending naked
photos and I mean all sorts of shit god
the amount of leaks that are gonna
happen during this is insane wild yeah
because I saw another one I haven't sent
a naked photo in lights like I haven't
had a drink and like counting the days
in like four or five years really all my
news would be then would be bangers wait
when you were in a relationship you
didn't send any no I did what like four
I didn't in my last relationship now
because I had a lot of friends had new
leaks but I didn't know that the new
leaks were from like ten years ago they
have them all they have them every nude
I've ever taken is in someone's Deep Web
cool and any new ones doesn't matter now
you put it out there you know it's gonna
be out there I guess I don't know it's
not out I mean if you just it's in your
phone you don't have to send them for
them to get them but people are just
intercepting our cloud good thing not
like I know what I'm fucking talking I
know you sent us so legit but I know you
don't know you just got a crop your head
out right yeah I mean that's what you do
you do neck you do like your neckline
attack out yeah Wow just now that we
have masks on we just have a nude with a
mask yeah what is it nude foot what's
the like now that I am like maybe gonna
date again why would I send a new to
someone there's go watch porn
no because it's you they want to see you
okay yeah they want to know what's
underneath that well get to it okay yeah
right what eventually you do get oh no
you mean in person yeah no I want to see
but for what cuz I want to make sure
it's running right what I'm gonna crop
I'm gonna pose in a way that it looks
like it does no but but there's a some
people look really good in clothes and
then they get out of clothes and they
don't look as good yeah but I'll be able
to take the photo from an angle guys can
tell no you can't yes they can no you
can't they can see if you have cankles
they can see they can see how your tits
lay I mean these are all these are
details no I'm gonna lay my tits in a
way that are gonna look amazing we can
tell we know guys know about tits okay
if there's one thing we know guy for
eight months that didn't know my tits
were fake and that's why you're not with
him anymore no it's not it's cuz he left
me because once he found out they were
fake he's like I'm a DJ I don't know
guys they have no idea he doesn't know
you're terrified did he feel then yeah
no idea what they dated Imran you dated
a moron you can feel fake tits anybody
know anybody but if you might know the
new kind now what is Tesla's you have
SpaceX they're very much if you plug
them in when you charge them get my USB
I need to plug in my tips before I gonna
switch you oh well it's a bit strapless
and Wireless no they're the new kind but
still yeah that you can still tell drunk
I mean there's a lot of oh let's get
into her yeah but I I think there's a
lot of things that guys don't know there
are things that I've hidden from men for
years yeah yeah deliberately yeah
there's things you will never know about
your wife stranger to you yeah sure I
mean but there's but isn't it partially
head fake eyelashes for two years ago
didn't I hair extensions you guys don't
notice we know that stuff I don't think
when you're with someone you do when
it's a stranger maybe not yeah that's a
when you're together long enough you
know because you find stuff like that
around the house yeah you see a fucking
chunk of hair what the fuck is that you
you feel it when it's in are you
definitely feeling when it's in uh-huh
but like guys but but like the things
that I don't want to know about her that
she's embarrassed about her doesn't like
what I'm he in front of each other uh
yeah I mean sure I guess you fart in
front of each other she doesn't fart in
front of me love it yeah I love it
no classy bitch but am I allowed to far
in front of her I just I don't because I
do often I hate this double standard
obviously but I do strongly believe that
just don't fart in front of your man
it's just a human nature thing yeah you
should be able to yes I know it's unfair
yes just don't do it yeah no there's
some things that don't you want that
isn't it for you more than like it's not
and it's not like breaking feminism to
be like I just don't want to fart in
front of them I'm just telling ya it's
just like a human nature thing the the
the people I know that are in the best
longest relationships are like I don't
shit in front of them I don't fart from
what about piss can you piss some I mean
I think guys are into like tink if it's
a tinkle what it can't be like a horse
race guys aren't into tank I just don't
want to think your vagina's like so big
that it's like he says who were you
getting this information from I just
mean like when I'm dating someone I
think men think when you have a strong
stream you have a huge vagina is that
guys there are guys I know that think
like Louis did that joke ages ago review
drink milk you come or yeah number like
I think like if I eat yogurt I'll fuck
harder like doesn't think that shit some
things do make you fuck harder by the
way like what certain certain certain
vegetables not true yes it is where is
the design game-changers didn't you see
that documentary they said a lot of
these guys that were vegetarians and
vegans they they had harder and longer
lasting erections but I'm just also
repeating like this kind of thing I
don't know if any of this stuff is true
it could be just kind of like you're
bald scientist bullshit you don't I mean
like women love guys who are bald said
the bald scientists women love fucking
vegans said the vegan this is this is a
problem with everything but of like of
course this reported by a vegan
sponsored company or do you know all
this you can't believe anything you can
always find something to support your
bogus argument at a dinner party this is
kind of like why people got mad when
Trump sent fake news you know like when
he coined this phrase fake news but if
Obama had said it yeah to criticize the
media it would have been valid isn't
that weird because the media does a lot
of phony bullshit like this is I don't
mean like talk about myself when it
comes to this and do you want to tell
your audience that you're voting for
Trump for 2020 she's all I know if I it
was so weird like I'm not a like blame
the media person but when I was doing
Roseanne which went great that was just
like a sound decision like super smooth
like I'm really proud of it ever really
yeah did that it was super fun time in
my life and there was a joke in it that
was like kind of like I mean it was
about I was just like I don't know I'm
sure like the left-leaning people would
have been like that's racist cuz you
just can't say anything right so it was
funny about yeah so it's fucking banger
yeah and I had written an op-ed and
vulture like a year prior saying I think
that both point of views deserve to be
represented on television totally which
is just like I truly believe that people
that are right-wing should be able to be
in TV shows so one that we should write
characters that don't only believe like
you know for whatever community tension
but I just every port of you deserves
we represent it because it exists in the
real world just that's what art is right
art is you don't say we don't pretend
that those people don't exist that's
stupid you know I mean you don't have to
agree with every character you write
there are great artists that wrote
pedophile like I can watch a movie about
a pedophile and not agree with the
pedophiles idea right I mean I don't
want to watch that movie but I
understand we just come from different
I'm kidding I know like I watched the
woodsman I don't think pedophiles should
are great yeah but in comedy all of a
sudden it's like if anyone disagrees
with you like the show has a whole show
has to get cancelled um dude yesterday
literally yesterday dr. drew tweeted at
me and said like like you won the show
my this effort that my effects show that
I'm on and I just wrote thanks brother
like just you know like he just he was
saying like and now he's going through
some shit or whatever that I didn't
really pay attention you cuz I don't
fucking care and he had previously kind
of like minimized Kovan
right like this isn't that big of a deal
right and he went back on it whatever
well that has nothing to with me I just
thank him for saying he likes my show
good taste in shows Twitter
Twitter was like how do can you fucking
be friends or support this piece of shit
that out of that it's like dude do you
think I control what everyone does
around me that's an insane idea but
that's when the internet and media and
headlines can burn things that don't
deserve to be set on fire I don't you
can deal with your problem with dr. Drew
separately don't don't leave me alone I
have nothing to do with that yeah you
know just I was at the party but I
wasn't drinking do you I mean but it's
also me not responding thank you is not
going to make him have not have done
that right but I think that people are
so addicted to outrage it is an
addiction it's a real adrenaline
addiction that people are just really
just wanna but I always I went into the
Twitter offices I talked about this when
bill burr was on that they said 20% of
America is on Twitter of that 2%
generates 80% of the comments holy shit
so it's not like we all it's also on us
to stop with the outrage I don't I don't
I just walk away but I go how could ya
takes the time to say it is not one I
just it's like it's like you know I was
sort of thing about it like before Cove
it happened and the big thing was like
comedians getting cancelled before we
had that thing called like purse back
but it's comedians like everyone's
attacking me it's like 50
it's it's not most people ya know most
people have jobs and they're busy and
they think collections going on
most people think jokes are funny yeah
most people do right you know so I think
that like people in America when we go
around really cause so-and-so you know
is canceled they're like I love that guy
yeah like they don't give a shit about
it I told you my parents when I said
Louie CK I um I sent you know started my
parents about watching a special and
they weren't really familiar with what
happened at all so just kind of like
yeah most people don't have enough they
were like where's Roseanne right I was
like oh well huh they're like I was like
oh well she sort of said this really
upset in between or like okay well we
went to tweet we could we can separate
her from the show totally we just want
to be entertained yeah they assumed most
Hollywood people they watch all day are
scumbags yeah I know they were all
disgusting like nasty rapists and
they're like we can separate you being
us come back from a movie we like but
why is it that athletes get away with it
more than than we do in our business
like why is it that that there is this
agenda that's been pushed that like
Hollywood is filled with like all bags
of trash but like an athlete beats the
shit out of his wife or or or fucking
gets into a fight you know and it's like
but they it's okay for athletes for some
reason like there's this class I think
there's two things I think certainly
athletes I said there's two things and I
don't know what the second thing is I
will come up with I just want to look by
myself a second the first thing I know
that I'm gonna say is that I think that
we have lower bar for athletes because
we're like well they're just animals
they're violent that's fucked up don't
you think
I mean I you don't feel that way I don't
believe that you mean keep them general
public people go like will they tackle
each other they're physical violent
people without restraint yeah but in the
same way we're less surprised yeah from
the people that are supposed to be
cerebral artists that write about
justice yeah but okay I know what you're
saying but in the same way I think like
yes people disconnect artists or I mean
disconnect athletes from humans right
they're almost like in the same way talk
about porn stars like these aren't real
people I pay to use them for my
entertainment but that's kind of what we
are - yeah right so I just I'm just
saying there's something about being
physically talented and dominant yeah
that lets it gives them this pod pass to
be kind of over the top as a human
because they're like well they're better
and I said everything so it's okay for
them to do insane shit I think it's like
when it went like a someone that's
violent for a living is violent in their
personal life yeah okay yeah I guess the
difference and then when it's like
someone who's sensitive for a living is
violent in their personal life you're
like huh what about when somebody what
about when somebody writes about when
somebody writes a movie about being a
sexual predator they may turn out to be
one shouldn't we just go well you know
surely yeah you should you should go
well that's the mean that's why it's
like the one thing which is really well
he kind of always did that yeah in his
movies what's surprising it was always
like an old creepy dude and like
Scarlett Johansson like why are we
pretending like he hasn't always been
this guy and then nobody would fucking
say he was a creep because we were so
used to being a creep that we were
desensitized and the movies were good
were they some of them which was some of
them name one buddy allen movie that
made you laugh besides Annie Hall well
it's not laughs it was more it's more
it's not a hahaha out loud it's more of
like a clever you know it's more of like
a oh that's interesting
I'm it's not a comedy in the th1 Vicky
Cristina Barcelona no I didn't like that
fucking match point it was a Blue Ivy
what is it blue Jasmine Jasmine good
sorry that's because of Cate Blanchett
so nothing else made it good no the
other actress in it was made the the
performances are amazing he hires
amazing actresses to do fucking boring a
scripts but maybe that's a talent it is
100 percent that's what I mean though so
that's valid directors number one talent
is casting right so they're a little put
people together that are dope yeah you
know you're gonna put Joaquin Phoenix in
Emma Stone a movie I like it even though
fucking and if you put any other actors
in here I'd be bored to death Emma Stone
Emma Roberts what's the difference I
don't know I genuinely don't know I
can't answer that honestly but the
difference can I give you another one
all white women look alike to do to me
you sexist racist well white women
without men appeal I like are you peeing
right now I'm gonna great I have to pee
too I was gonna say I was gonna say I
love Fisher and the other redheaded girl
that looks exactly like her
no but see there's another one Jessica
Chastain as far as I know I don't know
Jason Segel does Muppet stuff now hey
hey honestly he has better hair he does
Muppet stuff
who's my who to know what even what no
who's the who's who do I think is the
most attractive actress most attractive
actor to me is probably Tom I think Tom
Hardy is a sex machine
I think he's so because I don't like
boys I don't you know you know like I
don't like um pretty boys like I think
like I think Brad Pitt I understand that
he's attractive but I'm but he's not to
me right when he gets a little more
dirty yeah when he came out and said he
was an alcoholic in GQ I was like I
fucking love I would now that now this
guy's hot to me
I don't think Leo DiCaprio isn't now
he's not my style I mean like
attractiveness wise no way Jesus Christ
touch my face now let me touch your very
okay so Tom Hardy I actually agree with
you on that yeah I think Tom Hardy's my
guy and what's my woman who's the
actress hottest woman because men and
women always have difference this is
hard for me because I'm not good at
people's names I feel like guys like
Angelina Jolie and we're like no no to
both of those by the way uh I would say
new why too skinny too many tattoos
Billy Bob Thornton you are like you
don't like tattoos
no no hers are bad bad tattoos big
difference I like girls with tattoos
that are cool like what I just only
create awesome safety mmm now you've now
you're done you're on you're on my list
now it's out whoo so who's the hot who
to me who's the best-looking actually um
I think um I don't know because I don't
like any of the traditionals like I
don't like I don't like this is gonna
come out I think it no I think the
love to hear when a guy says I'm not
like I don't like I think I think you
know who's the most famous girl would
name some of the most famous actresses
I'm not going to say just googling
actresses I'm just not good at that I
don't know name a lot of guys I know
think rashida Jones is fucking the ha oh
like Scarlett Johansson hmm see Mila
Kunis mm-hmm yes I mean oh they're
attractive Anne Hathaway no Keira
Knightley no Huma Thurmond no Jennifer
Lawrence no Marianne koto Lars no Kate
Blanchet no prettiest face on the planet
nope
Mimi Adams that's who I think you were
thinking of me Amy Adams yeah that's the
one that's like I love fish yes yes all
the time I am my dad Kate Winslet no
Titanic yes no fucking go ahead Paltrow
Streep I'm just googling yeah yeah it's
hard I don't know I can't tell you who
do I think is like the hottest I think
I'm earning feminism points by being
like this isn't this is disgusting I
don't I just don't know who I don't know
who I think is like I just like I said I
said because I think she's like she's
mean I think she's just prettiest face
and uniquely hot like unique school
gadot yeah but she pissed me off with
the imagine thing so now I'm offer the
girl from this is the girl birth for
Alexandra Daddario from my friend
no buddy and I do think she's gorgeous
yeah yeah I think she's awesome kat
dennings she also attracted but I'm not
from know these are my top things I
don't know I don't know who's my thing I
love this
who's my one we'll find it does I just
assume every guy has like a girl they
Kate Beckinsale no cuz I every guy I've
ever dated there's like one girl they
have like a thing for and I fucking know
it I had it when I was a kid and not
when I was an adult when I was a kid I
thought Kathy Ireland was like the
hottest thing on earth do you remember
that thing you've ever said yeah
she now has like a furniture line and I
were you now bye we have Kathy Ireland
furniture at the house it's available at
Kohl's Walmart do you fuck it yeah I
fucked the couch come on Kath I used
have a poster of Kathy Ireland in my
house
so cute it's Agatha Helen was hot back
in the misty Brinkley loved her oh my
god she's bringing Kathy Ireland
yes Andy Crawford was I think I'm just
old I'm like getting older no I'm very
old people fuck this is so weird I'm
just realizing it's like and look I just
broke this don't don't break good studio
I know that was a big deal and the girl
from Caddyshack I just think I like
doing this cuz I think that I'm not a
pig like you I don't rank people by how
they look I had that every guy like just
fucking thinks about Jessica Alba all
day and then when I asked that she is
very pretty she's stunning
but there's just not one you know what I
just don't maybe I don't like actresses
that I think a lot of sex symbols are
more just to make women feel bad about
themselves and think guys actually you
know I'm saying yeah mine are more mine
are probably more real people than
famous people I think celebrities are
sort of built to make women feel bad
about themselves so products whereas
actual guys like yeah that's not even
what we think is hot no not really
I mean it's it's a trace I know it's
attractive because I know the symmetry
statistically but no outside of it no
yeah but like mine would be someone more
in the real world do you know I mean
yeah like there's a glassy gabbard yeah
like Tulsi gabbard's she's there's
something hot about her why can't people
say that she's know there's something
attractive about her not hot to
different things are they yeah I like Oh
cricket tooth you do you like one hanger
mm-hmm one little askew tooth I like I
don't like a lot of health care somebody
need me you like to be a healthy you
like them to be broken
I like ask raggle tooth for some reason
I know when I was a lesbian two months
ago because I worked on a movie and the
makeup artist had a Kurkure tooth and I
was obsessed with her and I was like I
think this is love no it's not because I
was so obsessed with her fucked up tooth
but that doesn't make you a lesbian
because you're obsessed with her
Thierry's out I was in love with her
uh-huh and then I got really confused
because she was like following me around
all day and like giving me all this
attention and my sister was like yet she
has to do that for her job or job she'd
isn't in love with you know I was like
she was like with me all day and like
she was she interested in women
Abbi you know no she's like oh so you're
just trying to really swinging for the
fences here I just have lost it
yeah I mean like fully you've gone up
off the d-pad yeah no I don't think I I
think
someone in the real world would
more attractive to me if I saw someone
out I was like wow that person is and
then they stay on my mind for like a
month yeah
you know guys have a type not real
yeah but the types as you get older they
get mmm
they change dramatically interesting
like like now um I think like a big
thigh gap is not attractive when I
probably used to think that in college
yeah that's a sick person a thigh gap if
your thighs don't touch you are you just
really tall and now your thighs should
touch don't alienate the thigh get
people some of these people exist
Whitney I don't know they exist I've had
a thigh gap but I've not had a thigh gap
but I know the difference I know the
difference yeah your happiness level is
levels through the roof I mean it's
anemia versus it's an iron deficiency
versus yeah like I thought like I guess
I thought when I was young that that
would that could I think everyone
thought skinny I think that's all we saw
when you were growing up totally super
scoopers hate the fact that Kate Moss
hey Moss was a beauty icon I think we
will look back it's like sickening
looking back but you have a most models
of that regard that's true our uniquely
odd-looking they're all kind of alien in
me but she was passing away yeah she was
crossing over yeah she died she was like
skeletally skinny yeah the fact that we
put that in the government used to smoke
cigarettes and drink and drink like a
great crime but it we did that but we're
just interested in how fucked up that is
she looked like remember that Marilyn
Manson cover loved it was just like a
skinny skeleton that is what she looked
like for real all the time was kind of
cool though
it's impressive for someone to keep
functioning like it was cool for like a
horror movie opener it wasn't cool like
put your dick in maybe every guy that I
dated when I was really skinny was
always like you're too skinny and I
didn't believe them and now I do guys
when they say that they mean it they do
yeah it's weird girls don't believe that
for some reason but we do mean it no you
just hear I need to lose my raise
because if I see a girl that's like my
wife is like all that you think that
chick is hot you guys do that sometimes
yeah is that to try to fight to have
good no no no no no it's like a
we'll both acknowledge if someone's
good-looking there was a guy in the
grocery store that I was like look at
this fucking guy she goes I know do you
see that guy was like if I'll fucking
annoying is that he was beautiful this
guy was like you know
he was like you any hat and you like
perfect bronzed skin and he had like a
kid with him and I didn't know it was
his kid or like he was an uncle or
something you know uh and he was like
being cool with the kid and it was
annoying how that's really good-looking
yeah and it pissed me the fuck off but
yeah we do that she'll go I'll you know
she'll be like I'll say I'll be like you
think that is that guy huh and she's
like oh yeah he's sexy like we'll do
that once an off for fun and she'll do
it with girls
yeah we'll both it usually happens kind
of organically so you practice saying no
to do you think that girl's hot that's a
good no no no no no I'll be genuine but
I'll usually go I'll have I have said
before enough to go up no choose to
skinny cuz I that is a thing that men
mean we don't like it when women are too
skinny it's a huge turnoff that's really
important unless you're a short guy
short men like really skinny girls
really well makes up at the fact they're
probably gonna be shorter than the girl
interesting yeah and I don't not you
know I'm like I need you to have low
blood sugar so you don't see how small I
am mm-hmm
I think we should tell my tiny friends
men that are short they need to have
very very skinny women in sure saying
yeah it balances it out you've got one
in the room right now like that me like
we weigh the same yeah yeah that's what
it is it's like you're 105 I'm 105 why
why is there still this fallacy that met
and like skinny women it's totally women
doing it to other women like it's like
fashion magnet you guys do it that's why
it's to stop fucking ragging on us about
this I know you know what's interesting
your podcast which everyone should
listen to your bad friends bubbie and
whiskey ginger yeah and what you did or
you did that too and um uh yeah that's
how it kind of how we met yeah I think I
we got along that would have been so
weird so bad I was listening to the last
episode and it Bobby
Bobby's numerous sexual assaults always
come up every time I didn't know how to
say sexual assaults plural sexual
assault yes uh and no one cares so if a
woman were to on a podcast talk about oh
these people I went to school with
forced me to suck your dick like behind
a tree it would be like front page news
oh ho yeah when men get sex resulted in
no one cares hold us no March there's
when men get sexually assaulted when a
comedian gets sexually assaulted no I
guess nobody cares yeah male get
sexually assaulted it's talked about no
they don't talk about they show that
they shut up they push it away I
actually tried to work on a joke about
this and it bombed first
six months I could not make it work did
it work no no no never worked it was
about like post me to it I mean and I
knew I had to put it to bed when Duncan
Trussell came out tomb was like that's
fucking hilarious and I was like okay
it's too dark hahahahaha Duncan is the
gage literally that is such a funny joke
I was like yep gotta cut it yeah it was
basically just about like the Catholic
Church scandal as someone that went to
Catholic Church I'm not attacking same
Catholicism it is what it is it's I
understand the positives but no one
gives a shit about all these kids that
have been molested
yeah good stories yeah my parents
wouldn't watch the movie spotlight oh
wow the movie literally gives proof that
this happened things can exist yeah my
mom was like I don't want to watch that
shit I'm like what why but there's also
I was trying to do a bit about how like
no one cares like you can't even help
even if you try to like yeah literally
Google Catholic Church survived there is
a organisation that that provides pre
free therapy for people that have been
abducted by aliens you can call a number
there's a whole thing you cannot there's
nothing no there's and I was trying to
joke about how the only thing you have
if you've been molested by the Catholic
Church is Alcoholics Anonymous and even
then you have to go to the basement of a
church like you can never get out you're
still there yeah and it's like there's
nothing that's led by a priest yeah it
does libraries and also it was just like
something about like how did we not see
this coming like they wear robes like
everything Harvey Weinstein did priests
have been doing for years I don't know I
was like and know it just bombed so hard
because so many people in that room had
been touched by priests and it was just
like religion where this just is - we
can't give up our Easter serve like we
just yeah it's a big no-no there's
Santa's boys yeah boy and people don't
care about poor boy rape is not taking a
serious there's no March there's no hat
but that's why with me and Bobby when we
talk about the sex sexual assaults in
the past the reason well but that's
honestly because it's it's also it's
okay first of all it's case-by-case oh
and his are particularly funny like a
little chubby asian boy stuck in a guy's
cock behind a tree is just some for some
reason we laugh at it because we know
it's Bobby but it's but it's why does no
one care or do anything about it because
Bobby has volunteered the information
from a point of him he doesn't feel like
a victim
right no he doesn't ya know cuz I maybe
he I don't know
I don't know his look we talk about it a
lot actually and I think it all kind of
came out and everything wrapped around
you think if I told a story about a
sexual assault same exact one and was
also funny about it yeah do you think
anyone would care yeah
so that even if I was funny about it no
because you'd still get flack for it
because because women inherently are I'm
not allowed to make jokes about it no
you are letting make jokes about of your
experience but because women are
inherently in more more commonly in more
of a threatening situation than men ever
are when it comes to sexually yeah just
societally inherently we we look at it
with a heavy heart because I know no
matter joking about it yeah doesn't mean
it wasn't inside the thing of like if a
guy falls down the stairs it's hilarious
if a girl's fall down the stairs like oh
my god are you okay Ben's on the girl it
depends on the girl there's a couple of
girls that would fall down stairs and I
would relish every single moment of it
just as their head bounced off the bump
this is great because this is my point
girls could be pieces of shit to
girlfriend I'm aware but it's also for
some reason societally we give more well
because because here's what I don't like
about it what I don't like about it is
like we can't we can't laugh at them
because they're more fragile like I
thought we're equal yeah we are we're
equal so I can take the same amount of
pain and criticism and all that kind of
shit
you know I just think the other side of
it we know how many more women get
sexually assaulted than men that's right
and the situations in that okay yeah
like look of the beside the precinct if
I'm going to the real world of like boys
who get assaulted yeah you know usually
by a family member which is same for
women but women get assaulted by
non-family my mean it's it's also just
like men don't get attacked in the park
nobody jogs inside no guys been jogging
yeah and then been raped well he'll
never admit it if he did yeah unless he
wanted it he knows he knows those pants
in a minute yeah what are you keep
running down that path if you keep
getting raped why it's a shitty shape of
your chicken legs over here yeah what's
going on it's really like as a guy you
can't even say you can't even talk about
it but it's been so funny to hear people
complain about I have a theory about why
men are so upset about coronavirus
so many guys I know are like shaken to
their cord left I can't go out and like
like I go they like people get you know
four feet away from me and I freaked
I'm like welcome to being a woman all
the time you're always scared of
everyone yeah you're weary all the time
like you never know who has it you never
know if they're it's like they're so
afraid of this anyone could be a threat
today and I'm like that's I'm we're so
used to that the cut your meters are
always on high that's women all the time
I'm always trying to figure how to get
people to stay six feet away from me
really yes no matter where you are we're
good at this where's your only comfort
where's the one place you feel
comfortable my liar lair in my home
surrounded by pitbulls that's it yeah
when you're in any public situation you
know I think that women were constantly
kind of like gauging like I think that
the way that we're all looking at people
now regards to shorty like is he wearing
a mask or his hands clean is he wearing
gloves like you're everyone's sort of
sizing each other up right to decide how
I genic they are hmm
women always kind of do that which is
sort of like people's vibes man and the
way they're walking and is he wearing a
wedding ring what's his deal you do that
with men not with women you're saying I
do that with men yeah I think there's no
gauge like that with women you don't
walk into a room with women and get that
same I think I'm slightly different cuz
we're like known yeah I will go like is
that person looking at me because they
recognize me or because they want a
picture like I have that little thing
that God a little bit where if someone's
looking at me because I feel like they
want a photo I'll just make you wanna
follow you say that all the time no way
if I feel like someone's like following
me around and they want to pick or
they're trying to figure out how to ask
I'll just I would say one out of ten
times they're like huh
no no I don't what do you mean and I'm
like oh never mind we're just walking
the same way I don't want to take a
fucking photo with you really yeah like
do you want a photo and they're like see
I asked that question when when we're
engaged in conversation and I want to
leave ya know so when we're talking and
trying to talk and I always go do you
want to get a photo but a lot of times
they'll go no I'm good to Mike okay I'm
gonna walk away now please I've got to
go this can't go on anymore I'm done we
did it but I I do think yeah there's
definitely a going out in the world I
mean certainly at night cuz I work at
night most the time you're like Here I
am and who is that person
yeah always gauging how close somebody
is and how dangerous they you feel say
for the club though I do it the Comedy
Store because Joe Rogan and Brendan
Schaub yeah Bryan Callen as the guys are
there are all there yeah yeah cuz it's
like your brothers are all there yes
like onto a family reunion and you're
like who's gonna fight me here yeah I
mean there was a time where Rogan wasn't
there and I was scared her right well it
was a little bit dirty yeah yeah yeah if
there's so many people around now but I
think that you know and I read that book
the gift of fear by Gavin de Becker and
it you feel right away when someone like
I've had a couple situations the comi
certain places in general where there's
so many dangers and you know right away
and yet you let me into your house you
write a fucking wait like if someone's
acting sideways like you just feel it
yeah no you can tell when someone's
being sketchy and I'm just gonna go home
like I get a weird there's no reason for
me to think this person's dangerous
except it feels I feel it can you check
out that fan and I'm like I'm going on
Wow yeah because I had like that's a
woman spidey sense more right away you
know right away because men see a weird
guy like that like this guy's gonna do
something fucked up I want to see it
yeah like we want to watch him be a
fucker you know I mean like when I see
someone totally fucked up at the Comedy
Store or acting very sketchy a nerd I
kind of want to watch whatever danger
they put themselves in I mean it's
happening more and more yeah I remember
and I but I also gravitate crazy people
for some reason it's just my vibe yeah
it is Dov Davidoff said once any time
we'd be talking outside the comedy store
he look every time I talk to you some
fucking weirdo walks up to you I'm like
that's not true he's like you gravitate
crazy people knows like no I don't look
over a guy starts approaching with a
full dollhouse on his head his act was
doing stand-up with the dollhouse and
his eyes peeked through the windows love
you watch me say hey wouldn t what's up
and I was like okay you're right you're
right
Thompson whose act like that's mark he's
cool that's a good guy how it used to be
alright we didn't get to all the
questions okay I feel like we've I don't
want to keep you any longer because I
don't want to ruin your marriage well
you did you already did what a time and
that's not that bad I do need a tinkle
okay so real quick and then I'll see cuz
I feeI find a question I'll tangle okay
I don't ask okay but I'll wash my hands
I do
Selena asked what is the one thing that
you Selena Gomez wants to know what's
the one thing you're missing in
quarantine that you didn't expect you'd
miss yeah that's a good question I would
say mine is having a real excuse to
cancel something remember when we used
to be able to be like hey traffic's
crazy you can't cancel a zoom
going to here at a restaurant I know I
also think like I didn't realize how
much I'd missed complaining about
trivial shit that doesn't matter cuz
like you can't complain about anything
because there's bodies in Central Park I
miss just complaining about spoiled brat
shit like just being able to pick I stub
my fucking toe oh and then they're like
okay well you don't have Corona who do
you think you are completely what's in
there oh my infrared Oh bring it in show
it no oh you just can't touch it it
doesn't touch my face that I haven't
used that math since pre kovat I think
that I just um I definitely am also miss
having respect for my friends because
now that everyone's always just doing
Instagram lives all day yeah I've lost
respect for most of my friends well it's
just isn't it hard to watch a lot of our
friends not be able to get attention
every second of the day
yeah that's really well that part I mean
some people need to post less do you
know I mean yeah it's hard to watch my
friends just like hey guys so everyone's
asking me what I should I put in my
coffee and I'm gonna tell you and I'm
like dude you have four viewers I'm glad
the celebrities are getting logout I'm
glad celebrities are getting hurt by
this like I'm glad people are being like
fuck you and we'll see you in your fancy
ass house I like that I think that's I
think that's good well also celebrities
just being like guys stay home it's like
if we had that home we would all stay
home but also saying stay home I think
there's a misnomer that's happening
people don't realize how many people are
also that have to work ya know people
like we can't stay home we're getting
groceries for you yeah yeah
what do you think we're doing I'm dry
I'm driving the truck so you can get the
shit and also some of us live with five
people would have jobs so staying home
is actually could be more dangerous for
us yeah it's better if I'm just out
doing whatever I'm doing I saw they were
at a place now Domino's is hiring by the
way if anybody wants a job there's
commercial they're running now every two
seconds I'm on TV
and it says like they need people
because
they just need more employees now
there's so much delivery yeah there's so
much going on I was like that's fuckin
wild so I've got a job at Domino's on
and on Ventura here I'm working I'm
working a shift tonight
are you 10:00 to 2:00 who's gonna know
you know what though I am I am I have
worked all sorts of jobs and there's no
shame and that if people are getting
have you that's why I like you my first
job was in fast food I work at
McDonald's with my first job I love that
15 baby flickin burgers really yeah
we're coming Donald's I worked at a
while I was I worked at the YMCA it was
a swim coach a basketball coach a
lifeguard I was a babysitter I worked in
cold calling sales of gutter washing you
know that you're our Rodney Dangerfield
yeah I can't wait to pop when I'm 50
that's that's why I'm rod Stacey wants
to know what prescriptions were taking
mmm what what is that what prescriptions
have you tried are currently taking
taking ambien don't recommend it unless
you want to wake up to 43 emails to your
ex that's apparent
I took lexapro and it I didn't like it
and I had bad withdrawals but I am now
on Prozac and I think it's incredible I
took zoloft when I was in college and
then I don't take anything right now
really good Wow
vide daily vitamin that's impressive
yeah I don't like drug I don't like um I
don't like thanks pharmaceutical drugs
interesting I don't take Advil really
yeah that guy I don't like that stuff
huh you know advocacy fuckload of people
every year you know that right people I
own advil because of your livery that's
terrible and I'm a drunk so I can't do
that do you drink a lot a lot yeah a lot
every night no Oh we'll see that's no
I'm not an alcoholic I'm just I'm a
drunk there's alcoholic needs the booze
a drunk loves the booze there's two
seriously that's a real thing so how you
it is a choice it doesn't make your life
I managable know you yet you seem to be
someone that really has a fucking
together on that front yeah no I know
look if it ever impeded me I'd put it
down I don't know I think control is
your primary dick I have to have I mean
you'd rather be in control of yourself
that's why I can't do certain drugs I
can't like Molly people like your
article I'd like to be in control
mm-hmm all right let's end on this yeah
Sheila
sounds like a fake name that's my aunt
it's definitely nice this is my aunt how
do you think people will behave once
we're back to normal
mmm such a vague question I know I don't
know I think handshakes are done yeah
but I don't like checking people's hand
anyway yeah I think it's good
I also is a woman sorry to bring gender
into this mm-hmm if you shake someone's
hand you get a grade on your handshake
oh by the Griffin man shit no that's
gross yeah like what why are we why are
you telling you know I mean that's like
an uncle telling and his niece being
like you really uh really filling out
there that's what that's the same kind
of gross or someone deciding your car is
too big for your body does that ever be
a car for a little lady big car like I
now that I have an SUV everyone's like
that's a big car but a car does say a
lot about a girl what I mean cars don't
mean much a car says a lot about a man
usually in a negative sense like a man
will get made fun of for having a
compensation but for a woman a car says
a lot about what you choose because most
women
Vegh look up it's a broad statement but
most women don't love cars most women
just have cars or they just you know or
get what they can afford sure my first
two cars were what I could have get for
the cash I had Hyundai Sonata
I had a Jeep Cherokee for like eight
years yeah cuz like it's a big I'm like
it's the only one I could afford right
so but I'm saying I know it's a that's a
broad statement but most women don't
love like I love cars most of my girls I
mean if a girl has a Jeep Wrangler she's
fun and outdoorsy and adventurous and
also she might yeah she might love
softball yeah well I have a theory
though every guy when I was in high
school that had a jeep wrangler was hot
everyone yeah it's like a hot person car
that is a that is a privilege white guy
car though you can't drive a Wrangler
and not be high you just can't and
that's a part of the thing they check
out yeah you've send in a picture before
you surf yeah what does it say four
girls got a mini a Mini Cooper mm-hmm
she's practical and cute and fun
peep-peep she might be a little
overweight
[Music]
so insane no I don't know she's cute
she's cute yeah she's cute she's an
interest yeah she's a little chubby but
she's cute stop it that's so mean what
if a girl drives a PT Cruiser a PT
Cruiser that she's from the past she's
stuck in the past I don't know how she
got here but she's stuck in the past
I hope I hope one of your fans how you
hit your lip yeah I hope all your fans
does Drive a PT Cruiser please send in
photos to Whitney if you drive a PT
Cruiser what does it say girl drives a
pickup truck like a Yukon it that's well
you cons on a pickup truck sorry you
mean just like it like an f-150 pickup
truck yeah like a Ford of her her dad
her dad loves motorcycles and she grew
up in that kind of culture or that part
of the country but see that's it's
country it's part of the country
dependent Los Angeles has different
rules you live in the settlements it's
your second car that's right so what if
a girl has a Prius it's also location
dependent right so like if it's LA
you're you did it because you if you
have a Prius in LA man or woman you
fucking hate cars you hate cars because
you have zero taste literal zero tasting
card is the ugliest the most unaesthetic
looking car I've ever seen I'll add
sheep no it's not cheap you have zero
taste on cars man or woman huh and you
just it's a literal functioning via to
get me from here to here that's any
previous owner was like it's just a
twosie dude I don't that's yeah it's
bullshit and they're shaming you for not
having a Prius just by having it and
Tesla is the sexiest Prius that if you
have a lot of money when you have a lot
of money you could afford a Maserati
mm-hmm but you get the Tesla to go
I like zum-zum fast E but I don't want
to look like an asshole
yeah that's really what it is yeah yeah
that's the balance I don't want people
to look at me the way to look at Brendan
Schaub yeah they don't look at him
you can't stare at that lazy eye long
enough and Mickey go nuts no but every
actually but you know what a girl a girl
in high school is he ever lazy eye oh oh
Jesus but I do but we could make it up
yeah he does broccoli Eric I have a note
olive flower that's so good I hate his
turnip here a girl in high school had
stick shift had a stick shift car and
there's nothing hotter girls the drive
stick shift better at hand jobs they're
better at everything i I don't think
I've ever given a handjob don't cuz it's
insane don't you I don't know how to do
it and I shouldn't you don't have a dick
why would any our women good at it no
absolutely no woman's ever been good at
it no I agree
no no Alba this Oh a woman is the only
good hand job consists of Lube or spit
it's got to be SATs yeah I said yeah it
get dry hand jobs is written circumcised
I have a I have a little bit of a shot
really yeah how many uncircumcised guys
have you been with a lot really I'd say
half oh man no I got a helmet I think a
lot more guys are uncircumcised but
they're embarrassed about it shouldn't
be embarrassed I don't I agree yeah it
looks the same when it's hard usually
and I there was an article I was trying
to write a joke about this I don't think
it ever came through about how and I
never figured it out that the emotional
trauma from if you're circumcised it
like fucks you up psychologically
because you associate your mom with
creating this pain why the mother didn't
do it yeah but a lot of times the mom is
standing there you know what I mean and
yeah but we don't know that we are car
brains aren't no we develop ya know
there's a little bit of sensation with
it I don't know no no I don't mean I
would know it I've never not had it yeah
yeah it feels just this it to me it
feels great interest yes I mean I can't
be underside of my penis I can't feel at
all but I think that's not you know come
on don't a lot of guys that are
circumcised though have lost some
feeling does it cut a nerve no I don't
think so I feel everything I don't know
there's no we have a friend a mutual
friend a comedian who can't wait to hear
just got circumcised as an adult no yes
was it wildly paying the comedian yeah
I'll tell you afterwards okay I don't
think I can't like I'm not close enough
to him to know if I can talk shit about
him publicly or not what did it hold on
let me back up two seconds of about the
car real fast
what does it say about do you judge guys
based on their car yes you do yes really
you have to I'm not I'm not happy about
it we just do this is we are animals
sorry when a guy drives alright don't
not about like oh he's got my eye
actually judged negatively guys that
have nice cars no I don't mean the money
part I mean the we're going back to just
the car really yes you'd rot you don't
like guys that drive nice cars you judge
them I don't know like what are you
trying to prove I just like what if guys
just like cars that's fine yeah I just
think if guys like you mean absurdly
nice like a Ferrari or like a what are
you talking Porsche Porsche Porsche do
you want me to say that you drive let me
I'll see that first
I'm not telling me you have a very hot
car for a guy it's a I Drive a coupe
yeah I Drive a two-door that's a good it
looks there's something kind of robust
about it you can't explain it's like a
little bit it's not a bitchy coupe no
it's about us yeah like it's like it's
got like like torque yeah that right
it's got horsepower and torque like it's
a fat it's like bulbous it's um it's a
twin-turbo v8 so very fast it's not like
a bitchy little car no no it's like a z4
a BMW z4 I don't know that is but it's
not like a tiny lady car no it's like
this is where I get so sexist no that's
good let's keep it going I want I don't
think guys your options or whatever
you're driving yeah a pickup truck in LA
yes no you can't have a truck out here a
Bronco well you're you in the big one
that looks like a big like boxy old car
I like guys with old cars like gee like
an old Jeep Wrangler like the I like
those but what is what is the thing with
the that's a big Bronco for some reason
I don't think of Range Rovers as being
expensive but I guess they are customer
had one there yeah there were hundred
grand oh yeah they're expensive huh then
the ones that you see when you see in LA
you're not like a forerunner or I know
fuck no no way
I think like like Porsche has an SUV the
Cayenne the or the Macan it's also an
SUV so good yeah no you don't like that
no nightclubs what if I go that's like a
second nightclub what if a guy drives a
like this is this is I'm gonna tell you
my honest reaction and I'm not
necessarily first a regular BMW 3-series
you don't like it okay
how about just a gent I'm dating an
agent that's an agent that is a that's
like if a guy drives a Volkswagen Jetta
oh boy see that's money judgment it's
that somebody says don't lie it's not a
money thing I like the Volkswagen truck
the Touareg the SUV you mean yeah the
Touareg I like the Volkswagen truck this
Volvo I'm thinking Volvo truck Volvo
I like the Volvo xc90 excellent the
Jetta I think I've just gotten dry
humped in so many Jettas that I can't
yeah like Jetta I think of a little
black forest green Jetta yeah that's
what he had yeah yeah honey I don't
think so I can't fit in it climb in the
back I'm a big person Honda Civic don't
I feel like I've dated a lot of drug
dealers that drive Honda Civics
and I think the rims or the wheels are
really nice yeah and they made them
really nice yeah I have good I have good
associations with Honda Civics III think
of cash lose cash loose there's money in
that glove compartment yes okay so how
like a lot of guys that I know that
drive Honda Civics were like criminals
not to me yeah are you like criminals
yeah motorcycles know you'll never day
to go my uncle had his head taken off by
a motorcycle why'd you laugh at that
part it was at the park but he got his
head ripped off yeah on a motorcycle
doing what riding it how did it happen
motors I don't I mean I don't have like
um I don't love motorcycles because
they're just so dumb they're dumb oh
they're just it's only a matter of time
when you're gonna die
yeah I've seen another of motorcycle
accident when I first moved to LA I saw
a horrible motorcycle accident and the
guy died and I had to call the police no
and I literally was yelling at a dead
body I was like why would you do this
why did you make me see this what did he
say it was right on sunset and La
Cienega right merica both people tried
to run the light the motorcycle tried to
run the yellow light in the car tried to
run the other life I saw the guy get hit
he went up in the air mm-hmm did not
think that's how it would go no they go
up flew up headfirst down somehow helmet
and then helmet yeah and then the shoes
were off who's always come off why is
that that's a thing I think
it's God playing a practical joke shoes
always come off for someone I looked up
cuz I just was like I didn't understand
much it's just so weird when you see
someone died in front of you yeah it's a
weird fuck up pic and then he started
bleeding and I started screaming at
having look why does it have to do this
and then I went to pink town and call
the police
I swear to God I was screaming at a
corpse so you don't like motorcycle I
was so mad at him for dying in front of
me because then I had to have seen it
the guy that you love more than anybody
else is in this world you meet him in
one month he's a motorcycle guy I've
said to many men if you ever get a
motorcycle I will be gone he's like
Whitney I'm the love of your life
there's I'm the only thing you're not
the love of my life would never fucking
put me in that kind of stress all right
I'm gonna give him more love of my life
would not what sayin he's gonna give her
the motorcycle I also dated a guy in
college who was like the hottest person
I've ever seen but he was kind of a
piece of shit and he got in a motorcycle
accident his whole face came off did
they put it back uh-huh and he looked
didn't look the same
motorcycles enough for you what's the
guy's perfect car what does a guy drive
them there you go you know what I'm cool
with like a truck I like I like an older
car you say truck you don't mean pickup
truck you mean SUV just like old I like
old cars you don't have any old cars
yourself you just want someone else to
drive old cars yeah interesting I like a
guy that's that's not like fucking
fucking wheel who's that guy
SEMA wheels man you know like I love
Chris D'Elia
yeah if a guy that I was dating showed
up in a taupe outie I would call the
police you would if a guy changed the
paint color of his car mm-hmm I would
never be able to fuck him again you and
him had the same car no we don't yeah
you do no we don't you used to you're
kind of right about that yes you used to
we weren't friends back then right I did
have a g-wagen for like 20 minutes yeah
and I realized it was a stupid I thought
I got it cuz I thought it was an old car
that's an embarrassing purchase by the
way agree I don't I judge people
whenever I see someone a g-wagen I go
dumbest car ever made fair dumbest car
ever mayor yeah agree and the reason I
liked it because it looks old and
vintage and I thought it was vintage
yeah
and I was like I want to get this never
like this is not an old car remember
when and earlier in the podcast you said
you loved not
that car looks like a Nazi my Jewish
friends would be like I'm triggered by
this car maybe they should be 100
percent it's like a German they would
say yeah thanks for the German tank the
parking lot no but Chris also has an
Audi that like yes like a fucking
shmegmer coloured yes it is most
disgusting it's like a mustard come
color yeah it's bad yeah it's he doesn't
but he but Chris isn't a car guy crazy
and then he had one that wasn't shiny
right here while Matt fit a guy that
makes their car Matt mm-hmm bill know
you don't like Matt cars no Matt can
look cool wear certain sports cars look
sexy Matt like Porsche Porsche can look
cool Matt a lot if a car has a lot of
lines they can look cool mattad I don't
know yeah but you know that you guys
don't get a lot of have things you don't
get to I don't have anything you look at
me I'm dead I don't have any you guys
have watches and cars that's all you can
that's true have that's socially
acceptable that's why when someone's
like when someone gets a little bit
money they do buy nice cars and and or
watches because what else do you want me
to buy yeah I don't shop I'm we're in
accommodation oh I noticed it's really
upsetting and this shirt underneath this
was free you can't do clothes huh you
don't do clothes well I came over here
like this because I wanted to be
comfortable no respect for me whatsoever
no not even a little bit but also you
know like yeah you are in sweatpants
that have is that chowder like it does
have white stains I just Coke I was
doing coke in the car before I came here
if you what would be the next car that
you bought if you just right now someone
gave you a free car what would it be mmm
god that's hard we talking during the
pandemic or I mean it forget pandemic
pandemic in the real world yeah what car
do I want next yeah like what's the um I
would love and I mean honestly if I'm
being like honest I think and I think
Aston Martin is one of the coolest cars
really oh I love Aston Martin's they're
so Sega's James fucking Bond dude how
much are they
anywhere from range 122 way way up you
know what happens if you see a girl with
a nice car are you more attractive them
or less attractive level how nice don't
guys want like a girl to be like it a
beat-up car that's about to break down
so you can help them no that's
disgusting
no because we also know women are pigs
like women are pigs there's this weird
thing that's like fucking women like
women are these cute Christian Christine
clean yeah a woman's bathroom in their
car or a reflection
and purse it's discussed inside of the
purse and they all look the same by the
way like always
across the board look at my wife's my
wife fell apart she had an old banana
peel in the center console and I was
like when were you gonna get rid of this
and she's like I'm gonna throw it away
it was it was it had been done when you
finish a banana it's done you throw away
the fucking same day goes in the trash
is her bathroom MS no because we know
it's not because of me coz my influence
now has taken over cuz I'm a neat freak
because you're the guy from sleeping
with the enemy or thy hands I am I'm
polishing stuff watching that movie and
thinking it was so hot it is hot control
yeah i'ma need Frank cuz my dad had
military kid syndrome wow I didn't know
that so I had my dad syndrome which is
like why are those shoes there that was
a thing in my house why are those shoes
there they go in the thing Wow
put the thing away place for them fuck
yeah that's why I don't have a lot of
stuff then I don't have stuff to leave
out oh this is why you're good comedian
cuz your surgical ICU trim fat I don't
need the shit what about shit like
you've seen my house there's we don't
have a lot of stuff it looked frankly
staged yeah it looks like a fake house
yeah cuz we don't like a movie set I
don't like stuff you don't have
tchotchkes you know have candles my hate
Chuck can you hate I I it bothers me
have you seen my office yep chachki
central I fucking hate knick knacks why
do we why do you have all that they have
so many knick knacks all I like to have
a little like thing of animals it's
your--it's what's up here
it's called hoarding its yeah
knick-knack e head I like you like I
like little things yeah why it's just
stuff to get lost this is my dream thing
put that down real fast I have no idea
what that is it's a cup no it's not a
cup it's a cup with little animals on it
do you drink out of it no never it's
just here cuz I like it and I want to
look at it so if you're my wife and
that's in my house I throw that away in
the middle of the night I would true I
would you wouldn't know what's gone
because you're a Nick you're a Nick man
haven't I
this is important to me I like looking
at it I like holding it I like touching
it does it have its it has sentimental
value horn oh that's your anime how guys
look at porn oh I look at these
tchotchkes and I'm like I feel better I
can now go on with my day
I'm a happy person I feel full that's a
sickness this makes me feel full yeah
but that is fixed all the invisible and
sinnin you know what it's now you're
more empty with knowing me that there's
a lot of finger prints on it now I'm
gonna
clean it and that's gonna make me feel
good insane I'm just gonna clean it and
I'm gonna fix my little thing and my
little bolt in my Lowell I'm gonna come
in here one day and just burn all your
child you know I think the only thing
that's better than this chachki the only
thing that's better than having this
Joshy is knowing that there's probably
other ones out there that look like it
and I'm gonna find them on Etsy that's
insane
so I will go on Etsy and look for the
family members of this Cup poor you poor
woman this is put that on your dating
profile Chatzky freak a you don't make
just one of these this is vintage and I
know there's much there's a thousand of
those and I'm gonna find them from China
they're all over the place yeah I'll
find them I'll find them I'll disinfect
them and they will be mine you can have
all of them and if I ever see stuff like
I'm gonna buy it for you like because
the problem is this is this is how you
start hoarding as you go oh my god I
have a thing and then you'll go to a
thrift store go oh my god I have
something like that thing so I should
get it to reunite them know which is
what does that say about me I'm the
office a lot of siblings I've never met
that starting to come to guess why I
need them they're out there like I'm
gonna reunite them your file from file
goes I'm 23andme reuniting cups because
I will never meet the sisters from my
illegitimate sisters and brothers oh my
god this took a turn you know always
that is like the theme of this my guys
it takes a real deep turn got done well
they'll help you meet him someday it got
dark that's always where things get what
if you met a brother on Riya what if
what if I would have forgotten bill burr
was like well this got dark yeah if it's
very dark he's like and I'm bill burr
okay so the thing is if I met someone on
Riya that's related to me the thing is
that if we are related to people
apparently they smell repellent to us
and we're not turned on by them why are
we then why is there it's like it's a
way to prevent incest is that you know
sometimes like girls just like smell
good that means you're not related to
them you know sometimes you're just like
someone's smell isn't good I mean you're
probably related to them in some way Wow
really yes that's how we've evolved to
not fuck our siblings Oh mm-hmm
but the Greeks did it all the time I
mean look then the Romans fucking they
look incredible see yeah would you be
fucking I say look in this dating app if
you say no to too many people they cut
you off for a while why because they
don't want you to just like treat it
like if how many people did you say no
to that it happened like five and around
one their fostering an inner they were
committed to fostering an intimate
community what could that even mean
we want to control your out of people
yeah we're honest people nobody's left
you hit the end that's what it means you
know I've literally hit everyone okay we
have to go it's a there yeah let's go it
is it's it gets late Jesus right Wow we
like each other we do but I didn't even
8:30
I know are you in trouble home let me
see are you gonna text your wife and say
I'm on my way home running late
not not cheating no no that if I say no
she knows we were doing the podcast big
nag but she knows yeah she knows she
knows she noted you descend I said hey
just finished okay cuz she said here cuz
this is scary update each other well I
should have checked in earlier and told
that we didn't start the podcast yet
because she was like are you coming
because it was a dinner conversation
from ok that's why we turn on the hues
oh you so curious in relationships how
much you have to update the other person
cuz I'm not good at that no you don't
wish I'm like I'll get home and I'm home
and you'll see me and you'll know with a
comedian she knows that because our
schedules are insane yeah yeah yeah but
but with this it's more with this it's
more uh no no we had a dinner that was
looking at she sent me somebody's home
she sent me a friend's house and on
Zillow see how much it is just to show
me that they just bought this house
these people that we know oh wow this is
a really pretty house yeah oh
Pennsylvania
yeah um okay tell me what else you have
a hit show at FX I have a show on FX
please watch it it's called Dave you can
watch it on FX every Wednesday and on
Hulu every Thursday and then you know
whiskey ginger podcasts go oh no listen
all of us listen to wits it's all so bad
and then Bobby Lee and I do a podcast
called bad friends that comes out every
more promotion it's doing fine it does
need more listen to it needs it needed
don't listen to it um and we talked a
lot of show we actually talked shit
about this show on there often yeah we
use the phrase good for you constant
just the subtle drop to make fun of you
you'll say something good for you that's
just subtle jab you know yeah don't
don't mention that yeah don't mention
that trash bag of trash crews the show
pretty much every time I read an ad well
cuz he sucks and he doesn't need more
he'd he's got everything happening oh
great he's friend
mm fuck him hi why I think you should
set me up with Eminem no why not you it
wouldn't work
why not you don't like hip-hop yeah do
not like that you don't know me
not like that what does I don't why do i
he doesn't which member of d12 died the
oldest one
okay very good but Eminem's not going to
quiz me on hip hop the name of Eminem's
first album welcome it is it's welcome
to Eminem Marshall Mathers LP no hold on
but that was the first big one I guess
yeah hold on yeah this is real I'm going
to the depths where you uh please stand
up you know dangerous mines nope that's
all I eat this is enough this date is
over
Eminem's first but he's not gonna be
like what was my first name of my album
nobody my kids but you bet his whole
world revolves around hip-hop so you'd
have to know you have to be a hip-hop
head I I think he would find it
endearing that I don't really know much
about his work and he wants to date
outside his this is how little you know
about him he's like a hip-hop nerd he's
like a he's like a freak with hip-hop
yeah and he would find it refreshing
that I'm not constantly talking about
the same thing he always has to talk
about hmm he'd be like oh my god you
know nothing about my world that's what
would you have in common then just like
just he would find it endearing and he
would want to teach me about hip-hop
he'd be like oh my god this is so cool I
can like bestow my wisdom on you and
it's so charming that you don't know
anything and I'm like your teacher and
you're like my pupil so you want to be
like love Anacin girls love me and I'd
be like play me that song I've never
heard it before
what is Run DMC I hold on the first
Eminem album no you wouldn't know you
really wouldn't know it I asked you I
asked you on paper smile no that's not
what no no no Marshall Mel he was a good
guesser that what I know more Eminem
lyrics than you do impossible I
definitely know you didn't even know his
first time out the one with pink more
than you know yeah you're right I know
the pink song backwards involved what's
the name of that song
the pink song I like this song the tell
him echo em I love you so much I'm a big
fan you are what song I like I think so
here's a daughter named Whitney so what
does that mean does he yes are you a
hunter personally and Whitney almost
paws
why are you stop that's my brand almost
positive mmm daughters prints no pink
give me just the the general I don't
know you're doing this girl M&M
daughters Hayley Jade Alanya and Whitney
Scott Mathers oh who knows more about
mmm now I don't follow his daughters I
don't know anything I know about the man
not his daughters okay
pink it's like we're gonna it's like a
very inspirational what you're doing is
very hip-hop so I love it right now
we're gonna wait that's kind of not not
it no it's a very pink I love this not
to collapse
not till I collapse not to like collapse
that's not till I that's I know I
definitely know that the moms spaghetti
huh I don't that song yeah very well
yeah if you were to play it I would know
it give me any of the lyrics from that
it hurts but he wrote down something the
words won't come out open now yeah times
up over bloah come back it sounds like
if my aunt if my aunt got Eminem lyrics
and read them to me that's it there's a
rapper rappers now need to go to the
roof collapse toughen down open up I'm
mixing with a holdup hey like I'm mixing
and who sings that take see you are a
hip-hop fan I know juicy backwards and
forward okay so give me the first lyric
and juicy this goes out to all the
people all the teachers that thought I
would never amount to nothing
yeah but that's him that's I'm just
talking and all the people that lived in
front of my building when I was hustling
Joe trying to make some money to feed my
daughters and all the blank in the
struggles it was all a dream
I used to read
up Magazine in salt and pepper and Heavy
D up in the limousine
go ahead hanging pictures on my wall
this is the part I know you're gonna
fuck up Magic's a turd
no sorry superset raps rap attack
Saturdays no mr. magic Molly Moll okay
you're that you were in and out there
you did like six different things at
once but yeah what is it rap attack
rap attack mr. magic Molly Moll
I hope this ends up in this is going to
be double ACP hordes like you want to
see some crazy white bed Mally mall
hanging pictures of mr. mayor used to
something in my tank top mmm sipping on
private stock something lumberjack with
the hat to match okay yeah with the hat
to match red and black lumberjack with
the hat - hat to match um see I don't
I'm too embarrassed to sing it but I
know if I sing why don't you just sing
it for um now I'm embarrassed
deputies sing it you said you can do you
were I just got America yes now after
this after ten minutes I outweigh Robert
Iger
any of my almonds okay we have to stop
because yeah it's like we do your rage
towards me is really a dad because I
love you and and this isn't it's enough
should we cut this out
no don't like it I was just endearing I
think the almonds are you gotta cut out
I mean I put a good for you and a symbol
over your mouth when you're chewing the
fact I'm eating is really disgusting I
know but I didn't have dinner you didn't
need dinner Oh
neither did I did you know I've been
here for 40 hours me yeah i we should
have done Rogen when i'm like my blood
sugar is starting to plummet his is hard
to do I can't be there for six hours the
last hour is really it's a marathon
holding on for dear life when somebody
says I want to do Rogen when someone's
like I want to do Rogen I'm like I bet
you can't better start doing crunches
now yeah because it's it's a mentally
hard to do because it's so long and
adderall yep pull it together and don't
uh and tread lightly you have to not
also you have to like use your energy
wisely like don't try to talk too much
in the first hour yeah cuz you have
three more to go
my thing with yet Rogen is the first
hour I just kind of shut up
that's smart cuz number one his fans
will like that I'm not talking and then
there they want to hate something so
they're gonna be I've now made peace I
like I didn't realize it was kind of
everyone you know I mean mmm-hmm
not everybody yeah I think Duncan
Trussell might be the undisputed champ
of Rogan I mean I probably get it harder
than most people about not most so some
people have gotten away worse than you
really significantly yeah yeah I think
Michelle wolf they were just they ripped
her surrounded by they we mean a very
small percentage of yeah there's other
people that go on there they get ripped
yeah there's nothing that don't want to
go on there because they get ripped but
I didn't think I didn't know that it was
kind of just like part of the deal
like yours just sort of yeah he's Rogan
and we're gonna sort of pick the guests
apart it isn't just two friends fucking
around like you do have to show up and
really be like ready well it's a hundred
million people a month I think it's too
many so yeah you know some a bunch of
those are gonna be that's right fuck you
it's nobody it's like it's a very small
percentage of fans but they but the
listen they're so many people that are
listening don't comment do you know I
mean yes how many more people are going
this is fun but they don't say it it's
like Yelp yes they like it and they just
go that was good episode yet they don't
yeah I don't I don't go I don't rate
restaurants I like a lot of them I just
go eat again I'm not a snitch yeah
that's right
that's right but uh but yeah the last so
now the first hour I try to just
conserve energy and then fucking then
just burst and I got shit to say that's
good yeah and now I know that now you
can say it's go the bathroom and go yeah
I didn't know it was an option I still I
still don't use that the first the last
hour you're just sitting there holding
your uterus yeah hoping to I don't have
one yeah right you know but I do hold my
bladder yeah I do hold my bladder you've
never asked a pee during the show no
I've had to a point where it really
hurts huh yeah I just hurts and I'll
just keep drinking to be like halfway
through Rogan just like all the time mmm
in fact sometimes if I'd you have to do
it twice too close to each other yeah I
get nervous I'm like oh man people just
gonna get mad people just get mad people
people people will say like oh you what
do you agree with Rogan too much it's
like do you want me to argue with him
though would that be a better episode if
i sat there and I said no to everything
that's so interesting yeah they're like
oh we flew well he just fucking agrees
with them
right on well next time I'll go for four
hours and we'll argue so why we're
friends yeah that's why he asked me on
the fucking show cuz we see the world we
have a similar point of view I don't
know yeah everything he says yeah and
those people get ripped to shreds every
time so it's like they hate you if you
agree to my I hate you if you don't
agree at all cuz I like to go like Oh
devil's advocate and they don't like
when I do that no usually Joe and I will
just joke about stuff that we both enjoy
yeah it's like it's just him and I being
goofballs nonsense we're talking shit
about a thing we just did yeah if I'm
like panicking that I'm being moring
I'll just like yell something about
science me like Jamie pull that video up
yeah and then hope that it like Jimmy's
like what's up I've been here for nine
days Brogan hasn't seen it yeah you know
he you know he lives there Jamie lives
there
no yeah he makes him sleep in the studio
yeah a little cot when Rogan leaves he
goes go to bed he turned off the lights
Himalayan salt lemon Himalayan mammalian
and Jamie only knows that Rogen's coming
in because he puts a rogen jay resembled
it's like a bat signal that spins on the
roof yeah it's like I'm on my way yes
that's how he used to wake up they don't
feed him either he's allowed to eat once
a month Jamie I don't think I met Jamie
to like the third time I did it yeah
they don't want you to mean I thought he
was just like a like I never saw him
that's very disrespectful
no I just mean I just was like I don't
know we know what you meant I blow you
like hands and just ijz a marionette it
was a Jamie yeah like he was just like
he's just a puppet on it it's not even a
real guy that's like Jamie like fake
purr and then I look at they're just
like that's Jamie he's wonderful I love
him you mean III think I'd literally do
a door of the times we've hung out I
don't think I know where he's like I
didn't I don't know him outside of wrote
yeah we only have cuz when we go on tour
when I opened for Rogen yeah Jamie's
come a few times when we've hung out in
he's cool he's just quickly just very I
wanted some cool dude fucking shirts and
they sold out like before I could even
buy on I'll give you his number
thanks I got the in I always had this
awkward late yeah it is let me end it
ready I think you've had fun I've had
actually actually I actually think
you've had I've had so much fun I
actually think we get along very okay
there's none so there's a couple times I
brought people on the pack I thought I'm
like I like you less but I like you more
well I like you way more oh I knew this
was gonna happen though what do you mean
dad we were gonna
a good time yeah there's only one
there's only one thing I don't like
about it that head I don't like that
head oh that's fuckin it that's an am
sommore head I got you to 8:00 tomorrow
with all the gas I don't like I know I
don't like that and when I first heard
the pockets I had a structure and I
don't anymore it wouldn't be worth it I
literally had like it all broken out and
I had the guests do the same every
guests do kind of the same thing and I
stopped and now it's just a fucking
mishmash of man yeah but it works really
what's the way we end it end it I
literally say I add these awkwardly and
I'm when I walk away you're gonna leave
me I get up and walk out that'll beat
you to it but I want to say all your
stuff first we already did it cuz I
think you you will get weird different
demos okay watch Dave on FX oh yeah it's
on Wednesdays it's on Thursdays it's on
Hulu then you can watch if you love that
show and people hate everything yeah
people do like it and listen to bad
friends and listen to musky ginger
podcasts both on YouTube and audio
everywhere and then um but is it on
stitcher yeah it's on it's on everywhere
they're on everywhere and go please
support my charity I have to charity can
I plug both charities yeah
the first charity that I really care
about is uh it's called turn them into
glue and I'm trying to collect all the
horses here in America and turn them all
into glue and the other one is band
pitbulls
so if you guys could support band
pitbulls and turn them into glue both of
my charities I'd appreciate it very much
I'm Whitney Cummings this was my show I
did a great job
[Laughter]
hey don't throw your tchotchkes at me
you fucking hoarder you hoarder no I
said hoarder goodbye
that was a fun episode
[Music]
[Applause]